all right guys I think we have a Quorum
at this
point so we can get
started
oh
doesn't but she sits right in front of
me and them all
okaying
stra oh thank you
Marty okay great
Mr Carlin if you wouldn't mind just
probably sitting close to the mic I'm
sure we're going to need you so you
don't have to keep getting up and
down all right so I'd like to open up
the work session on HB 1647 hb1 1653 and
HB
1673 um and start by saying I think the
reason why I would like to address these
three bills um together is because if
all passed uh they affect each other in
pretty dramatic fashion um from a
financial uh
perspective and so um
I'll just actually just um ask the
question to the room for the people who
are here and involved uh I am assuming
that HB 1647 at members of the committee
primarily towards you um seems like the
priority piece of legislation um is
there anybody who does not feel out of
these three if only one were to pass at
1647 is priority
legislation okay I didn't think I
thought probably everybody felt that way
um it has a benefit not only to the
group of employees from 2001 to 2012 but
it also affects um all of the um new
hires moving forward by upping their
multiplier um so I would like to start
uh looking at well actually let me just
say this for the members of the
committee uh and anybody else who's
listening um we know that the the
opening for 16477 itself has some
limitations to it
um the difficulty with this legislation
not from a fairness perspective or
anything else is the farther we get away
from the point of origin the more
expensive it gets to go back and fix
things um because the money hasn't been
in the system to acrw Value over time
and so every year that something doesn't
pass it gets more expensive to implement
it the next year and it'll get more
expensive than next year um Mr Carlin
handed out to the members of the
committee um a he just passed out a
sheet that shows the financial impact of
these bills um just at face value so
when we're looking at 1647 we're looking
at $ 55.9 million uh when we're looking
at 1653 we're looking at 26.6 and 1673
is $18.5 million if you put all that
together um at face value it's over
$100,000 um but because the other two
which one are this one here
100,000 100 million sorry yeah that's a
big difference I'm that completely
aw I'm just trying to trying to hurry
Peter so I apologize um but because the
other two will affect um
1647 um the cost is going to be much
much higher than $100
million um so I'm kind my personal
perspective and then I'd love to hear
thoughts from other members of the
committee first um um at this point
being 12 years away from kind of the
Inception of when these things happened
um we're kind of on a chess board that
no longer has a queen and we're maybe
down in Rook as well um and uh so I I'm
tentative to really um push very hard
for 1653 and 1673 my starting position
on those two is to move interim study
and I'm not sure if any members of the
committee have any definition feelings
at this point uh and then of course I'll
open it up to people in the room if they
have uh any feedback on that as
well do anybody really opposed to interm
study on that okay anybody in the
room
speak to
the yes um so we're just I was just
talking um about the fact that uh we're
we're making
1647 pretty much priority um and that uh
my initial gut is to move interim study
on both HP 1653 and
1673 and if anybody uh nobody on the
committee wants to speak to that so if
anybody in the room wants to speak to
that I just wanted to open that up to
people in the room before we dig into
1647 which will need a little bit of
work no yeah he'll come up to the
microphone so
I for the record Representative Steve
Pearson Rockingham District 13 Derry uh
Ju Just to mind the subcommittee here
these these two pieces of legislation
potential legislation here are sub
elements
of 436 is what they are they're they're
just they're just uh portions of 436
that were drawn out uh the the idea of
that um and the reason they exist is
because
of I'm aware of the House's position on
1647 I have confidence in The house's
position on
1647 but that confidence stops at the
wall so if you get what I'm saying
pretty hard I think yes so the purpose
of these two is to allow another
mechanism if necessary that that's
that's where um that's where that's
where these came from and also too just
to get an idea because of the
constraints that we we still have in the
ability to get data from the retirement
system due to the fact that they just
it's not free um this gave an idea of
what some of the sub portions of 436
were
because that was looked at holistically
right because it it did one thing right
and this just kind of covered some
elements of that just to see what
portions of
that how much different concepts within
436 cost if they were broken out
um so that's where these come from if if
the position of Edna is a full support
of 1647 that
is certainly acceptable and that is the
as the commission over the
summer reached an agreement on that that
does move the pendulum forward um so we
you know there's no there is no attempt
or desire to
derail that in any way so is just so
that you guys understand you know where
this where these other two bills are
coming from sure so interim study is
going to accomplish that it can it can
accomplish that um even even I would
almost ask
that we table one of the two of them
just just to have just to have something
as a mechanism if things go crazy when
it crosses over but we can still move
interim study and then move to table
absolutely absolutely yep okay great
thank you peon appreciate it um so with
that said we'll we'll deal with those
maybe later in this session um I'd like
to move real quick though to 1647 um
just because I don't know how much time
we're going to need on it and I want to
make sure that we can keep the ball
rolling um Mr Carlin I have a question
on um page two line two uh which refers
to the limits under RSA 100 a6a you're
speaking in 164 yeah in the actual bill
of 1647 yeah limits under RSA a6a which
doesn't appear to refer to anything
of the nature of what it's talking
about thank you
um okay this the a6a speaks to the
maximum retirement benefit um you know
which is the lesser of
$120,000 or
85% of the member's average final
compensation uh for anyone who commends
service on or after July one of 09 and
had not become vested prior to January
1st of 2012 so by incorporating
reference to that here the uh the
section of um H uh hb6
47 that you were referring to it uh
addresses the um
disability accidental disability
Provisions so so for accidental
disability for group two um the the
minimum payable is is
66.66% of uh of pay so that's you know
2third so the supplemental disability in
the statute right now uh is a protection
SLT trigger if someone was injured so
far into their career that with the
multiplier they would have acred a
larger percentage of their a see than
2/3 um the the uh you know the um that
is applied to the um you know so they
get that on top of the you know The
Accidental 2third plus plus anything
extra um it it does say you can't get
100% of your AFC otherwise or the AFC so
because you have the the different steps
in tier B and and then you also have
tier C there's five different maximum
amounts of years and months that you can
work when you until you get to 85% you
know or 100% you know if you're in tier
a so rather than enumerating them all
here where um you know it's you know you
know 28 and 23ds months for somebody two
twoth thirds years for somebody and you
know
29.4 years for somebody in a different
tier it it just the intent of referring
back to A6 was to keep though all of
those percentages out of this section
okay so you feel like that references
yeah we we we do as a retirement system
yeah okay yeah I just wanted to make
sure on that um any questions from
anybody on the
committee
okay all right so and then that comes up
again later on
as well so as long as we're comfortable
with that the retirement system is
comfortable with that I'm fine with it
um so other other than that unless
members of the subcommittee have any
questions we do have um a potential
Amendment which I handed out to you
before uh one of the concerns is that um
the body on the other side of the wall
still feels like this piece of
legislation is a little bit too
expensive at 55.9 million and uh we want
to make it as palatable to them as we
can so that we can get something done um
and so if you look at the amendment that
I handed out to you early earlier the
changes are in
red uh the one that I said you yeah the
one that I just gave you the one that
you said I'm not going to need it I said
no you are going to need it now is when
you need
it there's there should be red writing
on it Peter as well oh yeah you got it
no
okay
so this
um so the nature of this bill is that
for the first 10 years of credible
Service uh depending on when you started
your um employment um you'll get 2% to
2.4% um of a multiplier towards your
final average compensation um this adds
a little bit of a caveat to it that says
but only for members who work up to
their full age age and service
requirements and retire under service
retirement if a member retires prior to
reaching full age and service
requirements their annuity multiplier
Remains the Same as their first 10 years
of credible service which for new hires
would be 2% and then if you look at the
chart in the bill it will show you what
it is for the other members depending on
how long they've been in service um
prior to
2012 um so I'll start um I had a couple
of questions on this uh Marty first of
all from a an Actuarial perspect you
know
perspective this would this would create
two potential future benefits right
because we don't know when a person if a
person will reach maximum retirement age
so they could be building a benefit of
2.5% after the first 10 years or they
may be at
2% um any idea if that's going to cause
major problems for the actuaries if we
were to go in that kind of Direction um
it you know what what they would do with
if if something like this were to pass
is you know continue to closely monitor
the retirement patterns and in future
experience studies which are done every
four years to look at all the the
assumptions make adjustments going
forward as needed if you know depending
on on um you know what what the patterns
are so it it you know it adds another
layer of complication but it it's
manageable I mean from a programming
perspective it I think you know we have
to pull our hair out what's left of it
at the retirement Sy to figure out how
to do it but um you know that that's but
that's that's inside that doesn't matter
for policy but I you know the actuary
will you know when when any benefit
Provisions are changed um you know they
would look at experience going forward
and seeing how that's affected it and
and you know sort of keep fine-tuning as
needed every every four years okay
um
also unless I'm mistaken
um this would potentially have uh an
impact on people who end up on
disability correct because we don't have
a carve out for that so if they don't do
their full service
requirements um but not of their own
poition um that would have an impact on
them wouldn't it correct this this
amendment only speaks to service
retirement this is this is sort of
analagous to the $500 TSA Bill 1307 in
terms of should should those folks be
included because they couldn't you know
make it to full retirement age or or
whatever years of service type of thing
do we I mean we we won't have any way of
knowing the number of those people
obviously moving forward because they
haven't become dis disabled yet do we
know about how many people this would
affect in that interm
group um hard to say I mean the the just
just in terms of actual people who are
retired now the the um both job related
and non job related I think the um the
percentage in group two is um you under
10% for both you know so you know and
you know that's you know whether those
are folks who've been were disabled 30
years ago or you know last year I don't
have but you know so so it so the
percentage of group two disability
retirement is less than 10% of the total
group to a retire population right now
okay less than
10 okay any um if every is everybody
keeping up here or questions from the
committee or comments I
app
Peter thank you I think we have to have
some idea of what kind of numbers we're
talking about if people are going to be
involved in this
right if it was a under 10% of the
people that that sounds like it's
probably going to be
manageable uh if it were let's say 25%
you're going like oh that's not going to
work
so yeah representative Gard thank you
maybe I missed something which I did
show up a little late but this the
amendment says 55 million 900 right or
that's that's the cost of the original
bill or the um estimated cost of the
original bill this is um this amendment
would seek to bring the cost down fairly
substantially because a member would
have to reach their full retirement
benefit they'd have to stay for the full
number of years um and and work for
their full but there's idea at what that
number would be yet well it because it
affects people going forward it's kind
of impossible to know because we don't
know what choices people are going to
make in the future um but as far as
looking backwards I think we have an
idea for that group between 2001 2012 um
we would know who it would affect and
who it wouldn't because or for the most
part U maybe not totally but
in part anyway who it would affect just
just as clarification on on an actual
cost calculation to um the the the
statutory procedure would be if if this
amendment or any Amendment came out of
Edna and was adopted by the Full House
it would obviously go to finance next
LBA would reach out to us after it
passes the full body to redo the fiscal
note for for finance and same thing if
Finance amended it again we and it
passed the house we do a new bill for
Senate so so we don't can't get you the
numbers in here but if the concept goes
forward from this policy committee and
the the Full House adopts it you know we
that's the next step and when we would
be able to Value this um it would
somewhat reduce the cost but again I
couldn't give you a percentage or an
order of magnitude because there's a lot
of moving Parts there there were a
couple of proposals with the retirement
benefit Commission in the fall that
started out um adjusting the multiplier
in different ways and only for for tier
B and and the commission also asked us
to come back and say how much less would
that be if it only included people who
went under service retirements you know
similar language to here for those
proposals and these aren't apples to
Apple so I'm I'm only giving this as a
you know as a potential range order of
magnitude and it may actually be larger
but that reduced those proposals by um
somewhere
between
um uh six six and 12% on the UN of the
reduce the rates by between six to 12%
which reduce the unfunded for those
bills um 3.6 and between 3.6 and 6.7
million again dealt with the multiplier
but it was tib only there's other moving
Parts this includes tier C this includes
a future normal cost for TRC um you know
but just just you know I I I can say it
will reduce the cost
somewhat
right yes yeah it's part of the
challenge of of that's I'm not going to
be as concerned about the monetary
component of it because that'll be up to
finance I think it's probably good if we
discuss the um the policy components of
it at the very least here and decide
whether or not it's best to hold off on
something like this until it gets to
finance um assuming that in its current
state it would get through the house
safely the first time through um and let
Finance figure out if it's although if
we don't do this here Finance won't be
able to get those numbers correct if we
came out of finance and and you know
passed the house on on the second pass
to crossover we' crunch them during
crossover so the Senate would have them
in time to vote on it and finance could
always remove this if they wanted to
descend it back to the house floor in
its original form I guess so all right
so I guess we will look at it a little
bit more closely um as far as the impact
on um group two members who are on
disability um is there anybody in the
room who wanted to speak to that is
there any concern Mr
R
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Brian will uh
president of the professional
firefighters of New Hampshire um as Mr
Carlin mentioned this was a concept that
we discussed in the retirement
commission um to add in some sort of
guard rails that would not only help to
lower the cost somewhat um but would
also be somewhat of a uh a dangled
carrot so to speak for our retention
issue in the state
uh to encourage people to stay longer in
years of service um I think it's a
concept that was uh pretty uh well liked
in the commission um so I uh would be
supportive of this amendment um that you
have put out this morning um and I would
also agree in that carve out for the
disabled folks um because essentially
what that would do would be to not
penalize them um for their disability uh
and it would only um you know impact
those that chose to leave the fire
service uh on their own bition so I
would be supportive okay once again it
would be wonderful to know what the
fiscal impact is one way or the other we
don't um I just think from a policy
perspective it doesn't
seem doesn't seem right
to change somebody's potential benefit
because they get injured it seems like
it would be contrary to the purpose of
the disability Provisions but uh
anything from any of the committee
members I think I'd like to have some
kind of a feeling for what the what the
numbers would do I
mean even if we're I I I think I feel
much more comfortable if we would at
least strategize or game out what it
would be what with some idea of the
numbers if we're just saying
well well so I think I I think when it
comes to this particular am Amendment as
Mr R just pointed out um there's two
things to keep in in mind one is by
requiring a member to reach their full
retirement benefit to get the maximum
multiplier it's a retention carrot so
from that perspective we're just talking
about it as a retention you know carrot
will they stay longer will they stay
till full retirement so that they get
potenti I mean for new hires it' be a
half a percent added to their multiplier
which is a substantial difference to
their retirement benefit um so it is a
pretty decent sized carrot you know um
to keep them I guess it wouldn't be a
full half per it would be somewhere
between 2%
and probably four point something
percent but
um so from that perspective as far as
the cost the overall cost is we there's
no way to know like we can't that's what
the actuaries do and like it's a
complicated process and they won't do it
until it goes to finance so the whole
house will hear back on it will you know
finance will discuss the financial
impacts of it and then bring it back to
the house so we'll be able to listen to
their thoughts on it and vote at that
point but they won't run numbers for US
unless we've passed the house I'm I'm
certainly hearing that I understand that
yeah Mr chair yes if I may um thank you
representative for your concerns I I
would have those same concerns um I
think what's important to know I know Mr
Carlin uh touched on this as well when
we discussed this in the commission it
was on one of Senator Bradley's proposed
amendments and uh when we brought it
Forward uh correct me if I'm wrong but I
believe it lowered the cost
approximately $7
million um and that bill at the time
that we were discussing was only a bill
that would impact the tier B the middle
tier sliding scale group um this is a
bill that impacts not only that group
but the group that came after the TRC
folks so um you know if that was a
reduction of $7 million my assumption
would be uh that this with the added
folks added into this would be no less
than a$7 million reduction as well um
and the conversations that were had in
the commission were that uh this 55
million needed to come down 5 to 10
million in order for it to be palatable
in the Senate um which is where we're we
think this will put us right in that
range I think we have to at least Peter
think about it
like I I think we have to at least think
about it be be aware of it you know we
don't have to flesh it out
completely but we should at
least give it a moment's thought because
otherwise we're flying completely blind
I I don't think that's wise even if it's
not determinative we ought to at least
say okay on the one hand this on the
other hand that and so
forth well I think that yeah I mean I
think at the very least we know that the
bill as written is
55.6
million
um I think at the very least we know
that making this move is potentially
necessary for the bill to have any shot
um at least according to communication
that we've had that's exactly the point
I Mak yeah and so if if we know this if
the Senate won't even consider it then
we can't go that way if we want to get
anything done right so this would be
this would be a potential um Avenue for
that um we won't be able to vote on this
bill today anyway because I'm going to
have to go have an official amendment
made and we'll have to talk about that
make sure it's all polished up and
everybody's happy with it before it
moves out of the subcommittee anyway so
we won't be voting on that today just
kind of laying the groundwork so we can
go and and write one up to be disc
discussed at a future date um does
anybody else have any comments yep um
thank you Mr
R thank you Mr chairman um members of
the committee for the record my name is
Arthur bodri I represent the New
Hampshire State permanent firefighters
retirement Association and I have a
question um because if I'm looking at
the amendment which it says as
introduced but
um on the original Bill uh starting on
line
um s which page uh on the original bill
um
1647 as introduced which which uh page
of that bill though um it's the first
page the first page okay yeah where it
it indicates uh or a group two member in
service who has attained age 60
regardless of the numbers of years of
service May retire in a service
retirement
is the amendment I don't see that in the
amendment unless I'm missing it does
that affect somebody that were to be
employed in group two say at 40 years
old and at 60 they retired with 20 years
of service they wouldn't have um the
years and age as
indicated um for regular retirement but
at age 60 you can retire um regardless
of the age and uh regardless of a age
and years of service if you obtain 60
yeah there's no change same they have
the same what page are you looking at
because I don't have it on this on the
amendment that's Line
original the yeah they're not numbered
in the amendment but we didn't change
that portion there okay propos so
somebody that were to work start work at
age 40 at when they reach age 60 would
they would they get their two and a
half% for the years after 10 years Mr
cin
yes um that's how it's
applied that's how it's applied now so I
I would throw the question back to our
lawyers just to make sure but that on
its face that's how we would continue to
interpret it because it doesn't change
that wording at all right and and it it
is still a service retirement so
actually without getting the legal
blessing I mean it it's a service
retirement there there are two in group
one you know there's an age to be
eligible for Service retirement in group
two there's two ways for service
retirement meeting the minimum age and
minimum service which is way most people
go or a minimum age so that's still a
service retirement so that that
shouldn't change that for that person
who comes to New Hampshire in their 40s
and works 15 or 20 years because it's
still a service retirement right thank
you thank
you represent
pearon
think I just want to touch
on a potential if I can maybe help your
representative SMI just a little bit the
the numbers that were
crunched in the subcommittee that Mr
real talked about it with the with that
the middle tier guys right that's a
population that exists right now of it's
what is the number it's dropped it's
164 166 16 1642 1,600 A5 people roughly
right okay the population of tier C
after that is three times that size
potentially right so if you if you take
if you
extrapolate a savings for this group and
then you looked at the group after
that's larger you it would be fair to
reason that that the adjustment would be
that would be larger as well so the
target I think is what he's getting at
is the Target that they're trying to get
at here is obtainable or at least
appears to be obtainable based on what
happened during the
commission and the various things that
they they played with back and forth
because the retirement system provided a
lot of theoretical stuff and there were
a lot of proposals that that were thrown
out that didn't happen but there was
numbers with those and they were josling
back and forth is to a way to come up
with something that worked based on that
so you know when when you're looking at
a finite group of folks and then you
look at what comes after being a larger
group you know what I mean I think that
we can get to the theoretical on that
without having to get too overly hung up
on exact numbers which which finance
will get right so in a PO as a policy
committee that Edna is I guess the the
real focus is does this idea work and
then Finance can tweak the what you know
what the retirement system will provide
them after but the logic I think is
there for for the goal okay does that
make sense to you y yeah I don't think
we
should I don't think we should dive off
the diving board until we at least look
to see if there any any water in the
pool uh and so we talked through and we
have some idea we we understand that
this is not going to be fine-tuned we
need the exact numbers for that but at
least we talked about the general
concept okay with it and like I said I I
think that if the theor if the
theoretical on that didn't work we would
I I would certainly be going hey whoa
time out right but it it it does here so
uh you know I I don't think sending this
over to finance is going to come back in
with some sort of like holy cow holy cow
number right I I I just don't see it
it's just it's just the way that the I
mean the retirement system has been
functioning now for a long time time and
the patterns that that happen start to
become fairly predictable in certain
ways so this is this concept's not we're
not in inventing A New Concept or a new
way to deal with something we're just
putting some guard rails on what is
already existing that if I if that makes
sense to you Peak okay so and I think
the other thing to keep in mind too is
this is a cost reduction measure it's
not going to be a cost increase measure
so we'd have to ask ourselves the
question what's the concern that it's
not going to reduce it enough or that
it's going to reduce it too much um
because those are kind of the two
options on the table it will reduce but
is it going to hit the mark that we need
or is it going to go Way Beyond the mark
that we need and I would say I guess if
it went Way Beyond the mark that you
need then you know people might be upset
that they were giving up benefits for a
specific group of people that they could
have had within the price range that's
your risk there um but and if it's not
enough then it might just not be enough
to get it through and find will have to
look at that um when it gets there um to
see if there's another way to you know
cost save but those are really the two
options the thing is too on top of that
is we're talking
about numbers here that frankly are
absorbable okay within not not only
within the realm of the Surplus but in
the you know in my conversations with
the speaker there's two other pots of
money that exist where that could that
he is willing to use to make this work
so we're you know we're not talking
about you know the G the addition of $50
million or the reduction of it the
numbers aren't that huge it's it would
be little bits and pieces where you know
if if someone's Line in the Sand is $48
million and this is 48.5 are we really
going to kill it when when we have some
wiggle room really to to make things
work yeah there's there's definitely
wiggle room to make things work I would
agree with that so we've had this
discussion because the alternative is we
don't have the discussion and then we it
comes before the other group and
suddenly we say oh we never talked about
that well we have talked about well as
well too as as as you're well aware I
mean subcommittees bring forward to the
full committee so you have
to not necessarily sell it but you have
to be able to present it right and and
show that you thoroughly vetted what you
were looking at and I think that that's
I appreciate you doing that so
okay anybody else want to speak to 1647
today I'm still not clear with that
language that's fine I mean it's going
to have to go into Amendment anyway um
so it's it's going to come
back yes Mr Carlin I just thought a one
other point to make it's not a you know
a deal breaker but I think it's a good a
good fact for the the subcommittee to
consider so any reductions as a result
of this amendment would be on the
unfunded liability point portion the the
way the bill was constructed is
introduced the 55 million is expected to
cover the unfunded piece for you know
the tier B andc members affected
basically any um so the normal cost
would be the same so that rate increase
of 094 and 95 you know wouldn't be
affected by this this is only on what
the appropriation for the unfunded that
the state would be putting forward I I
think some of you may have been aware of
that already and with unfunded ability
just if you think about it the closer
someone is to retirement you know the
more unfunded is with them it's almost
like a slope you know what I mean if
somebody started yesterday they don't
really have any or today they don't have
any liability associated with them and
we don't calculate it on a per member
basis because that wouldn't be you know
wouldn't be fair you know they they
calculate it as an aggregate number but
if the the liability another way to put
it is the LI the unfunded liability for
any of these bills on tier B is more
than on tier C because they have been
here less time and they're going to have
to work longer to get out you know type
of thing so that just just sort of to to
help frame the thing so so you not
saying you this this will reduce the
unfunded liability by some amount and
you know if if it if it was you know
approved we'll be able to tell you
reasonably how much um you know so so it
is definitely going to cut the cost but
it's it's all on the unfunded piece so
that's the piece that the commission and
members of the commission wanted the
state to front in this case so it
wouldn't be passed on in rates to the to
the municipalities and schools right um
just clarification on that though with
the potential amendment that we've been
discussing with the potential reduction
of the rate if they don't reach their
full retirement service um that would
have elements that would be a reduction
to the um municipalities and
would it not because we wouldn't have to
charge them as much in the future I
understand what you were saying actually
the the the the this amendment or you
know wouldn't change what the projected
future employer costs are because it's
it would be reducing the unfunded
portion that the state was you know
paying you know you know on delivery if
you will you know so it it you know it
it will reduce the state appropriation
by by some amount but the FY 26 2728
costs of the change would be the same
okay gotcha you know well you know it'll
be the same there might be some changes
for patterns in the future as as if not
everybody in TRC there's a percentage of
people who drop out before they meet
their age I shouldn't say that
completely but that's not going to show
up for you know a few Cycles right yeah
that makes TT sense okay anybody else on
1647 okay I see no more conversation
thank you Mr Colin I think we're all set
um I would like to
um discuss then uh
1653 uh modifying the definition of an
earnable compensation for group two um
and I would like to move interim study
on that just curious if I have a second
on
that second from representative Gard
you um I would just say um we discussed
it earlier in the day and everybody
seemed like they were pretty amenable to
it everybody out there seemed amenable
to it um it leaves us with some wiggle
room some some way to work with uh bill
to work with if something happens to
1647 and um does anybody else want to
make
comment okay well then I will go ahead
and call a vote on it all those in favor
of proposing interim study on 1653
that's
unanimous
okay
okay you're back l so I can't see you
you yeah I saw that
yeah all right and then um see if I have
a paper there it
is and then uh once again on
1673 um I'm going to move interim study
for the same reasons do have a second on
that representative Gart thank you um
any
discussion same situation yeah all those
in favor then of recommending interim
study to the full
committee unanimous all right guys thank
you so much we got 15 minutes
until our regular
meeting and I'll close the subcommittee
hearing thank you
good morning everyone welcome to Edna
I'm open the public hearing on House
Bill
1689 and I call Representative
Canon oh representative Bolton excuse me
my my mistake you're i i i mistook what
was happening representative Bolton
please
chair Maguire and and members of the
executive um committee oh crap I right
off the
bat Matt you can give me a heck next
Monday when we meet um the uh the house
executive departments Administration
committee and for the record my name is
Bill Bolton I'm a representative serving
the towns of Plymouth holderness and
Ashlin in house district 8 I thank the
chair and the committee for the opport
un to testify in support of House Bill
1689 this bill clarifies the law
regarding how identifiable information
contained within a vital record is
collected and reported to other state
agencies I'm the former state New
Hampshire um registar and was the
director of the division of Vital
Records Administration under the
Secretary of State in 2005 the
legislature made a policy decision to
move the division of Vital Records from
the Department of Health and Human
Services to the Secretary of State
State along with a support from the the
Hampshire City and town uh clerks
Association we pursued this legislation
because there was a shared concern with
how the very personal information that
is collected during the birth and death
event registration was being
shared when a mother gives birth in a
hospital she is asked to provide
information that includes both
demographic like Social Security uh
number full name of child father and
mother address and whether she was
married or not and also personal
information like alcohol use during
pregnancy smoking before and during
pregnancy there used to be a threat of a
class B felony on the worksheet if the
mother refused to provide all that
information on the form thanks to the
legislation brought forward by Senator
rosenal last session the threat of
clasby felony was
removed but in reality it doesn't matter
if the mother refuses to provide it
private information or not because the
hospital retrieves that information from
their medical records and shares that
information with Vital
Records the mother's information that is
transmitted to Vital Records now
includes all her recovered demographic
data and additional items such as if the
mother had gonorrhea syphus cyia during
the pregnancy as well as the total
number of other pregnancy outcomes like
abortions there is no informed consent
offered to the birth mother to stop this
she has no opportunity to stop her
personal data from going to many
agencies and her name is linked to that
data for future disc
Discovery in compliance with a
memorandum of understanding jointly
written after I left State Service uh
between DHHS and Vital Records the
entire data set of Vital Records is
given daily to
DHHS DHHS in turn redistributes Vital
Records data including identifiers to a
series of other program areas within
DHHS and Beyond to include the Bureau of
Information Services the division of
Public Health Services the division of
program quality and integrity the
division of Economic and housing
stability the division for children
youth and families the division for B
Behavioral Health the Bureau of Legal
Services a state recovery unit the
division of long-term supports and
services the division of Medicaid
services the office of Health Equity and
the New Hampshire retirement
system I know that the programs under
dhh DHHS are extremely important and
they do great work furthermore DHHS puts
safeguards on staff that access this
data but having this data go to many
staff in many programs uh increases the
possibility of misuse and causes the
complete loss of privacy of our
citizens privacy has always been a
concern and this legislature has
recently supported two bills that ensure
privacy during January 3D's house
session SB 255 relative to the
expectation of privacy pass pass the
house on a Voice vote and allows New
Hampshire citizens the ability to opt
out of large companies use of their
personal information House Bill 314
relative to the expectation of privacy
in the collection and use of personal
information also passed on a Voice vote
during the January 3rd house house
hearing this bill determined that
service providers covered by hb3 314
hold some of our more sensitive personal
information and they must obtain
permission from any individual before
the company can use it privacy rights
have quite a history in Hampshire while
serving in the State House honorable
Neil Kirk was a fire brand in his
respect and pursuit of safeguards on New
Hampshire citizens privacy
representative Kirk drafted a con
Constitutional Amendment enshrining
privacy into the New Hampshire
Constitution which read an individual's
right to live free from government
intrusion and private or personal
information is natural essential and
inherent the amendment was put to a
general vote and became part of the New
Hampshire constitution in November of
2018 with res with respect for the good
work that representative Kirk did as a
legislator this act should correct the
current practice of sharing very private
vital record data with other state
agencies despite the fact that none of
the mothers who gave birth had given
their permission to share her their most
private information so I urge that Edna
committee support HB 1689 to correct
this unfortunate breach of privacy thank
you madam
chair thank you are there questions from
the committee representative
black uh thank you I've got a couple
questions one is um you know limiting
the access of information on Nal with
the uh for nality so for someone being
born you know I completely support I was
actually a co-sponsor on Senator Rosen
wal's uh bill um but I have some concern
about uh mortality because um I think
there's a more general interest in
understanding why somebody's died
because that can have an effect on
everybody you know there's been some
recent experience with issues around
that um so that's one question the other
one is have you looked at uh Senator
Rosenwald has another bill in it B 484
this year related to the birth worksheet
I was just wondering if you'd looked at
that and if you see any interaction
between that and what you're proposing
here um regarding that the bill I I'm uh
I signed off on that bill so I'm also in
support of Senator Rosen Wall's new bill
see I I looked at it looked so followup
sorry followup so um I look it looked
like it would interact okay with this
but I was just wondering if you looked
at it yes thank you on that one and she
indicated that she was support of this
bill as well so regarding death
information yeah so um death information
you know at least the the um the event
and the death are public the identifier
such as names and you know anything that
would identify the decedent is not and
we've always shared generally the death
information in fact it's still um
available online um through an
application that we developed when I was
the registar called NE never in web and
you can go in in query um all of the the
death records um for specific icd10
codes or um and you can basically see
all that information online but the the
identifiers are not they're not open to
anyone without a direct and tangible
interest in that record brief follow
yeah um so as I understand what you just
said that right now the personal
identifier information is not available
to the public and if that's the case
then what would this change so what um
the public is different than the
Department of Health and Human Services
um what um it basically they get all the
Death information as well including
identifiers and as I indicated that just
by sharing um that that data with far
well the the vision of V record is
actually a very small department and
also they're imbued with the the need
for privacy and they so there's only
like um maybe four four or five staff
that actually have access to the data
but when it goes over the DHHS you have
perhaps like 15 program areas that have
staff that look at it so my um concern
is that there's more of a chance of of
vulnerability and release and misuse of
that data so we've increased that that
possibility
right thank you you're welcome represent
Ro thank you representative Bolton how
is this bill different from s SP
105 which was the bill last year that we
amended because there were significant
issues with that there was um I just
might I recall that that Bill had um
additional um removal of certain fields
and such um and actually I think that
that bill um
had the ability to break the connection
between um Vital Records um providing
information to uh that's not it oh yes
it did have a that's
right it didn't allow because of the as
a result of s SP 105 information
important for Vital Records such as
birth certificates were not going to be
able to be
issued I didn't quite uh understand that
from the bill I thought I was more
concerned on the fact that also too
there's a lot of like data sharing
between contractual data sharing between
vital records and the national Center
for Health statistics and Social
Security Administration for death and
birth rep representative both the main
point of that bill when it first came to
us was to eliminate most of the data
Gathering and and so that the the useful
data that you need for birth certificate
like the child's name and the parents
name was not included so the was not
sent to Vital Records this bill doesn't
appear to limit what information is
gathered just what mostly what vital
records does with it that's correct and
I didn't sign off on the um the last
bill from last session what I did
totally disagree with uh was the
appearance of a class B felony on the
forms that collect CED the data and that
has since been removed but that data is
still being provided to uh M vital Ral
you know vital records and through that
Health ins Human Services follow up
follow up thank you and the contractual
agreement between vital records in the
Department of Health and Human Services
is still honored correct yep actually we
have a state regist current state regist
here that would probably answer that
better too yes thank you okay any other
questions
represent Brown uh thank you madam chair
real quick could you repeat the name of
that app that you mentioned I didn't
catch it it's never in web it's nhv r i
n web NH v r i r web thank you and the
current state res can determine whether
or not I think it I believe it's still
very active and your ability to query um
death you know birth and I think fetal
death as well okay thank you marriage
divorce but all right there no more
questions thank you for your testimony
thank
you now representative
C thank you madam chair and fellow
Representatives my name is uh Jerry
representative Jerry Canon represent
straford District 12 which is
summersworth and Rollinsford
I'm primarily concerned about identi
identity
theft and
um just to give you a little background
I'm was a computer professional for 31
years uh involved with introducing
electronic mail products to the N to the
world um and very complex networks and
we what we thought were highly secure
networks turned out they
weren't
I'm
concerned that the hacker
industry is progressing with their own
software on a regular basis they get
updates to hack networks and systems and
when you can't get into one system they
update their software to get into
another I was a victim of identity theft
my credit card information my name my
address was stolen and I had to go in
and change all of all of the the credit
cards I
had U I know other people have
experienced it and it's a very high
incidence of that and we hear daily that
there are other networks even in
government agencies where those their
networking systems are hacked for
information I'm also concerned as we as
information is shared and I know that or
I I would hope that our networks are
highly secure is that we also have the
human factor of how that information is
handled and what might be left on a
desktop that somebody else could find so
it does concern me it's multiple points
of access to additional
information so I am concerned about
those multiple points of of access as
well as the information that's
shared I know as far as the birth
information it seems to be that that
that information has felt held very
tight but I'm concerned also about death
record
information we've seen problems with
voting and information about individuals
and their address information being used
to
spoof the uh their their pole booths to
get in and I'm concerned that
information that is available especially
for death records could be used um for
the wrong
reasons and I and I'm also acutely aware
that during a death that it the family
should be in control of whatever
information is released for public use
and I've seen as far as death
announcements is not a whole lot of
information about location is being
included on a lot of those records
now and thank you for listening to me
and I'll take any questions you might
have thank you are there any questions
from the
committee no thank you some very good
point thank you uh Christen
Kennison give them that
in
you should turn the mic on it' be it
easier oh there we go thank you uh so
I'm Christen kenniston I am the current
register of Vital Records and I am here
to obviously talk about this bill um
just so you know we're not coming in
with a stance to um oppose or support I
just wanted to point out some things
that I noticed within the bill that I
should make you aware of from aital
records
standpoint um so I will start off by
saying that we don't have any concerns
about adding the term and definition of
personal identifiers to RSA 5 C1 um but
there are some areas Within Chapter 5c
that are not being addressed within this
bill that um could create some issues we
need some clarity on so under RSA 5c3
and 5 C5 basically says that the
Secretary of State shall not remove or
add any data fields used for purposes of
protecting the public health or to
conduct health related research without
prior notice in agreement of the
Department of Health and Human Services
so by eliminating the data fields um
that dvra is sharing with
DHHS I'm wondering if the bill would
contradict that statute um under rsa's 5
C12 5c 101
5c3 excuse me 5c 103 um talks about
tangible interest so as um
representative Bolton mentioned and you
need tangible interest to obtain a
record we're not an open record State
you actually have to have um a relation
or some sort of a legal purpose to
obtain information so right now with the
way the statutes are the Department of
Health and Human Services does have a
direct and tangible interest our our um
agencies are linked in the sense that
they would need to access our data for
child support services um things of that
nature so there have been times where
when they go to court for whatever
reason we've issued certified copies of
Vital Records to them for that purpose
so I just need to know would we still be
permitted to do that or what kind of
restriction would this bill place on our
ability to issue certified and not just
to that agency other agencies that might
reach out to us looking for certified
copies so I would just need
clarification um the bill restricts the
sharing of Vital Records and statistical
data to the Department of Health and
Human Services solely to mortality and
natality statistics it further mandates
three removal of personal identifiers
before sharing rsa's 5c4 and 5 C9
establish memorandums of understanding
between the Department of State and the
Department of Health and Human Services
the Department of Corrections and the
New Hampshire retirement system in which
limited personal identifying information
is shared RSA 5c4 also requires the
intradepartmental sharing of personal
identifying information between the
division of Vital Records and our
election division to assist in
maintaining the accuracy of the voter
database so both of those divisions are
part of the Department of State and what
I'm referring to is um death information
is provided in a way that it can match
up within their system and automatically
flag a voter in real time that this
person is deceased which allows clerks
to then update their checklists and
remove that deceased
voter um currently divorce and marriage
records which do not contain health
statistics but do contain personal
identifiers are being shared with DHHS
under our existing mou the bill would
discontinue the sharing of the divorce
and marriage information with them um
because there's no health statistics to
associate with the personal identifiers
in the deaths and marriage one can
reasonably assume that the linkage
between the health statistics and the
personal identifiers is not the main
concern of this bill um it's solely for
limiting the release of personal
identifying information so that
naturally raises the question as to
whether the Department of State will
still be permitted to continue sharing
personal identifying information from
vital records with the Department of
Corrections New Hampshire retirement
system and if we can continue our
intrapersonal our intad departmental
sharing of data to keep our voter
checklist um current the proposed change
to RSA 126 24d is contradictory to other
statutes that Define the memorandum of
understanding between the commissioner
of the Department of Health and Human
Services and the Department of State the
change would seemingly have the
Secretary of State and myself who are
part of the same unit enter into an
agreement with one another as opposed to
us having an agreement with um DHHS but
it's under a DHHS statute that's giving
us that link so I see a little bit of an
issue that we would need that clarified
so that we have the right guidance um
and furthermore if the division of Vital
Records is to assume dhs's current role
in releasing approved vital records
information for health related research
more work would need to be done in
chapters when 126 which is public health
and is in charge of the vital records
privacy board and then also to chapter
5c as I've pointed out um areas would
need
clarification the bill doesn't
appropriate any funding to the Secretary
of State's office and there will be some
fi uh fiscal impacts so when we first
learned of the bill we anticipated an
impact of under $10,000 um just by
simply limiting the data exchange
between us and between DHHS but not
knowing exactly where this is going to
go how it's going to affect other
memorandums of understanding and also um
us taking on the role of the Department
of Health and Human Services releasing
information for the health related
research I don't know what kind of a
fiscal impact that would have I can say
that we would need more staff um I would
end up having to defer to Health and
Human Services for some guidance on how
many staff they currently have in this
role but I'm anticipating at least a
dozen um so just to put that out there
and if I need more staff um I would
actually need a larger space to house
them our building that we're in is
deceptively larg looking because the
bulk of it's the warehouse so um and we
share with archives and our elections
division so um I just want to keep that
in mind that if we do this that we're
going to have some big changes not just
with how we're doing things but where
we're doing things so that is all I have
today to offer you if you have any
questions for me representative laus
thank you um I couldn't get all that
written down as you're going through I'm
wondering if you could list the specific
concerns rsas related and all that and
send it to the committee yes and at
least give the committee in the option
of considering maybe some exceptions if
that we go that path yes I can do that
okay thank you okay other questions uh
it sounds like it would need to yes it's
going to um I think this is
representative
grotus I served on the vital record
record privacy board
for I don't know five or six years
anyway I think several terms I'm now on
the vital records Improvement um
committee verifact we call
it and so I'm very concerned about this
issue and I I would appreciate it going
to subcommittee would you be available
for that Madame registrar yes thank you
okay thank you repres man py thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question since when it's totally digital
you probably have the archive of
physical files some some okay yes so
what is the year it was completely
transitioned okay so it was in stages
but births um was around I believe it
was 2002 I think we have paper copies up
to 2001 of all birth records and when I
say paper copies of birth records as a
reminder for those of you who were here
during SB 105 we don't have the birth
worksheets with all that information on
it I just have a simple certificate
onepage document per per person born um
death records we are still trying to
transition to electronic but it is a
hybrid right now of electronic and paper
marriage is also a hybrid of electronic
and paper it's all keyed in
electronically with a city clerk or town
clerk and then the marriage license is
issued for use and then when it comes
back it's filed and kept on file in the
paper format with the division of Vital
Records so we're running on a hybrid
system right now um most of our records
are available in electronic database
whether they exist on paper or not uh
for example birth records we can go as
far back as
1935 that you could go anywhere in the
state and get a
copy thank you questions representative
gold and beyond that there are
electronic images from the open records
the early records available on family
service ancestry.com yes y we work hard
with um ancestry.com thank you for that
okay thank you and I'm sure we'll lead
your support for the subcommittee okay
Patricia
Tilly good morning chair good morning
members of the committee I apologize for
my froggy voice uh this morning my name
is Patricia Tilly I am an associate
commissioner with the Department of
Health and Human Services and we are
here today in opposition to HB 1689
relative to the use of personal
identifying information by state
agencies because of the breadth of the
impacts my written testimony is quite
long so I apologize in advance it is
quite detailed it gives a number of
statutory references that I know um will
be important for the committee to
consider um um so I will just hit the
high points right now we've also
provided hard copies of our fiscal
impact um we know that the OS is working
like crazy to get stuff attached we and
that was not yet available to be
attached electronically so we've
provided you the hard copies hopefully
the electronic stuff will will catch up
along the way um so we do not take
opposition to this bill lightly but
without Vital Records um with its
personal identifiers the department will
be unable to fulfill its core statutory
functions to protect and to promote the
health well-being and economic stability
of all of the people in New Hampshire
Additionally the removal of this current
access will cost the state not only in
tens of millions if not more of lost
federal revenue but foundational complex
DHHS Data Systems would need to be
completely
redesigned because we at the the
department are entrusted with this
sensitive and private data we have
rigorous data governance that limits
access to the information so if I I own
that means the people who have access
have a tangible need for that as an
associate commissioner I can't see that
data as someone who works in a child
support function they can't see the
Health Data all of the data is strictly
limited to who needs it to get their job
done HB 1689 has far-reaching
consequences it impacts access to needed
healthc care services it impacts
economic supports it impacts our ability
to detect fraud uh for New Hampshire
residents without access to this
information regard that includes an
individual's name their address and we
assume that's also their zip code in
their Town their spouse's name their
children's name there even their social
security number really unimaginable
things will happen
our federally qualified Health Centers
may lose their Federal support and be
unable to serve 880,000 low income
people in the state in need of health
care families in your communities will
not receive the child support to which
they are entitled the department will
not be able to facilitate International
adoptions so that children can have a fa
ever home and the department will lose
the tools they need to fight Fraud and
Abuse the department uses this data
every day if the department doesn't
provide these Services it's unclear
which agency or entity would or if New
Hampshire's would not be entitled to the
same benefits that every that citizens
in every other state currently have
while very well intended 1689 puts the
health and the economic security of our
New Hampshire residents at risk last
session we heard um that this committee
considered s SP 105 and that was
relative to information collect Ed by
vital records as part of the live birth
worksheet we worked together on that and
at the time the department testified it
a significant unintended consequences of
that
legislation um and you all heard
testimony from healthc care providers
Community stakeholders families and this
committee unanimously decided to remove
the restrictive sections of that bill
and pass other important privacy um
components that took away those uh legal
ramifications um but it maintained the
department maintain the access that it
needed in our testimony today you're
going to hear similar themes broadly
speaking um aggregate deidentified data
about births deaths and other records
are insufficient for the works for the
Department's responsibilities as RSA 5c
States the department has a direct and
tangible interest in these records and
we will not without it we will not have
the abil ability to respond to the
health needs of mothers young childrens
and infants with health issues it will
take away the ab capacity of the
department to establish parentage and
paternity which will result in children
losing economic supports it will take
away the capacity to understand unusual
patterns in deaths as the state registar
noted there are many areas of the bill
that contradict a broad range of current
statues that are on the book it doesn't
provide consistent definitions and more
work would be needed to untangle that
spider web restricting Department access
and Vital Records sort of affects four
broad areas public health and Health
Care access for New Hampshire residents
a legitimate investigations of Fraud and
Abuse of Public Services federal funds
for the Department the loss of those
federal funds and the unwinding of
foundational Data Systems and um even if
the committee you know believes those
risks are worth taking the whole whole
work of
untangling um uh the legislation or the
statutes throughout our statutes so a
little bit more on public health and
Healthcare um without access to Vital
Records more than 85,000 New Hampshire
residents may lose uh access to their
federally qualified Health Center why is
that it's not that they couldn't do
their work it's that their designation
as a federally qualified Health Center
depends on the vital record birth data
so that we can say that something is a
medically underserved area these are
federal constructs and without that
designation they don't get the
additional money both from the federal
CMS from federal U um US Department of
Health and Human Services or CMS it
really undermines the entire system per
on a more personal note in New Hampshire
we use the vital records for newborn
screening last year you may recall we
had a really impassioned family come and
talk about about what that's like for
them to make sure that their child has
access to those new newborn screening at
Birth and that the state can ensure that
services are implemented right away if
one of those children have a positive
screen for a time sensitive congenital
condition these are conditions where a
baby looks healthy and gets sent could
get sent home and be just fine but in
reality may have a chromosomal disorder
that they need to change their food
right away or a treatment needs to begin
away before there is loss in cognition
or health function that's how we use
vital records every day um at you know
if we talk about economic supports and
and Human Services we look we know that
the complete birth record allows the
department to verify citizenship to Aid
in eligibility for Public Assistance
programs such as tanith snap child
support Medicaid the proposed changes
would delay the process for deter
terminations by limiting access to the
identifiable information to verify their
application without the ability to
confirm the name the date of birth the
residence the paternity the maternity
the responsibility to provide that level
of pro of of um verification would fall
upon the client and failure could result
in a denial of benefits additionally New
Hampshire residents seeking things like
International adoptions would find
barriers years as the division for
children youth and families will not
have access to the required data to
complete the federal requirements I have
a very long list in the in in the um in
my written testimony so I will stop
there there are some technical and Hippa
issues um HB 1689 creates these radical
and far-reaching changes on this
Authority and it impacts a number of not
only state statutes but Federal statutes
it puts us in conflict with several
federal laws for example vital access to
vital records information is required by
the federal Social Security acts in
order to implement the child support
program it puts us into a quandry when
it comes to Hippa as many of you know um
Hippa required the creation of a
national set of Standards to protect
sensitive patient health information the
Department of Health and Human Services
is a HIPPA covered entity and so it
complies with those Federal requirements
to protect and and secure health
information the Secretary of State's
office and their division of Vital
Records is not a HIPPA covered entity
nor can it can it be so it puts us in a
difficult place because of that Hippa
standard it's the reason why I know
representative Schmidt and others who
have participated on some of the vital
records privacy board that
responsibility is given to the dhh s to
ensure the security of the health
related information because we're the
agency that is Hippa covered um HB 1689
also proposes um eroding RSA
12624 and it removes the authority of
the department to Steward and and
release that potentially private
information so this is a place where in
fact it may erode existing privacy
protections and may open the state up to
significant liability and potential
costs if there was a privacy be breach
um or unintended receipt of that data
under DHHS control of the health
information the Privacy the data may
actually be strengthened so there are
federal implications one of the other
pieces is just a reminder from last year
we know that about 10% of New Hampshire
residents give birth outside of New
Hampshire and in New Hampshire about 10%
% of our births are actually to
Residents from other states it makes
that interchange between the birth
certificates very difficult and
something that we would have to to learn
more about and finally there's money I
will not you have the fiscal note in
front of you the it the num the number
is indeterminable but it is certainly
north of tens and tens of millions of
dollars tens and millions of dollars of
federal grants that the state will no
longer have because we will not be able
to meet our responsibilities for those
grants it is also the funds that would
take to unwind and redo our Data Systems
the tremendous amount of money that is
on on the hook right now but more
importantly simply the services that the
that the people of New Hampshire depend
on the Department of Health and Human
Services for would not be able to be
completed and someone would have to do
that or as as I noted our residents in
New Hampshire would not have access to
the same s sort of services that
residents in every other state have we
understand fully understand that New
Hampshire has a strong tradition in
protecting privacy Above All Else and
because of this the department takes its
role in protecting this sensitive and
private information incredibly seriously
we have rigorous user access to specific
data sets only a very limited number of
Staff have access to just the data they
need um we Implement rigorous training
in privacy in Hippa in cyber security
all like I know our colleagues do at the
vital at Vital Records we are committed
to using this information as authorized
in current statute to help prevent poor
birth outcomes prevent child abuse and
neglect ensure that women and infants
receive the appropriate life-saving care
that they need and that that New
Hampshire residents have access to all
the various social services and
assistance programs to which they are
entitled we believe that as a HIPPA
covered entity the department builds in
those Safeguard safeguards those Vital
Records data with protocols that secure
those personal identifiers and protect
confidentiality DHHS and the division of
Vital Records have an efficient
effective relationship based on solid
policy written M us and trust between
our two State agencies DHHS uses our
federal funding to help support their
infrastructure and modernization saving
General funds 1689 would fundamentally
change this relationship and would cause
frustration for for New Hampshire
residents and will likely create
unfunded work for other state agencies
we know this is a complex Bill we are
happy to work with the committee in any
way that you see fit in in order to
untangle some of the web so thank
you all right thank you are there any
questions representative
Schmid thank you madam chair and welcome
commissioner uh it's a pleasure to see
you as always uh and I do recall the
bill from last year very well and we had
active participation at the time from
from several families and and you've
referenced brief in your in your
testimony the fact that some uh some ACT
actions have to be taken
immediately uh with
newborns uh to screen them for uh some
diseases or situations that uh can be
lifechanging um uh and we had several
families uh that that testified at the
time question representative Schmidt say
what your question please
yes so uh uh you will be available the
chair has already told me that there
will be a subcommittee so uh Will you
she already said she would be yes I we
will be we will make ourselves
completely available to the committee
and to the subcommittee we know that
families depend on the life-saving
connections that we make with um newborn
screening um to address those rare
heritable conditions even though they're
rare it's very real for the families
that they impact so the question that
the chair has asked me to to put forward
apologize for the for the Preamble but
the reality is that the families that
are involved uh need to be notified so
that we can hear from them can you can
you we will do that yes thank you thank
you representative Gard you had a
question NOP all right well that's fine
anyone else
representative G thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question um
just to make it clear you talked about
security of um the information
electronically to the staff of Health
and Human Services so to make sure
everybody understands when you log
in the security level is is attached to
your login into the computer system
correct that is correct and there's no
way for people to get around that
security system there is certainly no
way that I know of that people can get
around that security system and i' just
add quickly even I worked um on bridges
for DCF and I was in charge of reporting
so I had a really high security level
but when we had really hard uh need for
security there were even cases where
Flags could be put on that even at my
high security level I did not have
access to information on those cases are
you aware of situations like that AB
absolutely each one of us who works for
the Department of Health and Human
Service serves has roles assigned to us
and it dictates what you can see and
what you cannot see and the vast
majority of people cannot see anything
that has personal identifiers attached
to it it's really very specific to your
very specific role that you can see that
box of data and that's hardwired into
the data yes and we have folks if you
have very detailed questions we have our
um head of Information Services here in
the gallery if there's deep questions
that you need to ask thank
you thank you for that um don't see any
other questions thank
you Brianna
ankle
good morning my name is Brianna hle I'm
a legal policy fellow at new Futures new
Futures is a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization that works to increase the
wealth wellness and health well-being of
New Hampshire health and
wellness new Futures urges the committee
to oppose this bill because of the
unintended
consequences um currently the US has a
matern mortality crisis and one of the
federal grants that New Hampshire
receives is for the maternal mortality
Review Committee that reviewes reviews
um maternal deaths and gets information
on what causes them
and um and be able to improve
outcomes uh another example is the the
infant screening that was
discussed um other funding like tanif
and captive that are used to help
families would lose funding as well
um New Hampshire doesn't have the
infrastructure to fund those programs
alone and so we need the personal
identifiers to be available to the
department um does anyone have any
questions all right are there
questions I I think not thank you for
your
testimony Aubrey
Tanner
hi there um my name's Courtney Tanner it
just shows it goes to show my
handwriting is terrible this morning I'm
sorry about that uh Courtney Tanner
senior director of government relations
at Dartmouth Health uh Dartmouth Health
comprises um Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical
Center the state's only academic Medical
Center and our three Community Hospitals
Chester Chester New New London and Alice
P day hospital we also have community
group hospitals uh community group
practices rather in Manchester conquered
in NASA and Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical
Center is home to Boston um Dartmouth
children's hospital and is also referred
to as Chad we have 30 intensive care
Nursery beds and we have the capacity to
care for complex infants and newborns we
also have the ability to care for
mothers who have the highest needs of um
clinical care Acute Care in our state
and because of this capacity we often
see um mothers who uh have the most
complex um labors and deliv iies um in
our state we're proud to be the
administrative home of the Northern New
England perinatal um Network which we
call nequin this is a Consortium of
multi-disciplinary providers in both um
in verain Vermont and Massachusetts and
we they work to collaborate educate and
Advance care um for expecting mothers
postpartum women and their infants and
children in uh in nor Northern New
England as a treating facility uh and
home for quality improvement initiative
depart withth Health has significant
concerns with heal spill 689 as as
introduced specifically the changes in
the data collection on the live birth
worksheets has submitted to Vital
Records it would impact our ability um
to access Federal resources to analyze
and improve infinite and maternal Health
Care delivery in our state and it would
have potential
um potential impact on our citizens
abilities to access important documents
vital documents like birth worksheets
and adoption records um I'm happy to
take questions I do want to thank this
committee for its work on sen on Senate
Bill 105 last session um dmouth Health
also opposed that bill last session and
we do see this bill as pretty similar to
that to that bill and have are now
raising this similar and same concerns
so um thank you very much for your work
last session and we hope we have the
same outcome this this
year are there any questions from the
committee you're okay representative
Schmidt or you have a question have
question thank you uh will you be
available for the subcommittee this is
very important absolutely thank
you all right anyone else I don't see
anybody all
right Hannah
bedoy
good morning chairman and committee
members thank you for allowing me to uh
testify today um on behalf of the New
Hampshire Public Health Association we
urge the committee to oppose House Bill
1689 relative to the use of personal
identifying information by state
agencies nhha is a membership
Association uh for and of Public Health
health professionals we have over 250 uh
public health organizations and
individual members uh our mission is to
improve the public health House Bill
1689 has significant unintended Public
Health consequences uh it limits the
department and the public health sector
ability to identify health issues in New
Hampshire develop and Implement Public
Health prevention and intervention
strategies design and Implement public
health programs and education services
design and Implement maternal
interventions um tailored to our
population measure infants and mother's
health progress and recommend
appropriate Public Health policies and
programs to improve the public health
this bill impacts the health of
approximately 600 infants receiving life
saving care and treatment 400 infants a
year needing hearing screening services
and treatment and followup for at least
30 infants uh per year diagnosed with
hearing loss if this Mill passes infants
and mothers would no longer receive
timely identification interventions and
treatment to prevent significant Health
outcomes we urge the committee to oppose
House Bill
1689 okay thank you very much are there
any questions representative Brown uh
thank you madam chair and my apologies
to the rest of the committee as I'm new
to this and I don't have experience with
your some of the history that's being
discussed here
and I I'm going to put this question to
you that I could have probably put to
others
so why is it that this if this bill
passes that it will impact the health of
600 approximately 600 infants what piece
of information is there that doesn't get
passed along
somehow um can you can you elaborate a
little bit your second and last
paragraph Yes Bill impacts the health of
approximately 600 infants receiving life
saving care and treatment at etc etc
what H how do and maybe someone in the
committee or others in the in the
gallery could explain later how exactly
does that impact I I don't understand
and subcommittee I would probably get
that
but how it will impact them uh they will
not be receiving these Services these
are life saving Services Madam chair
representative Brown the point is
that no one other than Vital Records
would have things like the name an
address of the mother or child so you
couldn't get in touch with them yes
they're not going to be able to
implement these services or go to their
homes and provide these screening
services okay that's that's at least
part of it there's more but that's a
okay I I will to later to the department
for accurate accurate numbers that's
fine I I will I'll I'll learn more as we
go along thank you madam chair thank you
okay thank you chair anyone else all
right um Ben
Bradley good morning Madam chair members
of the committee my name is Ben Bradley
for the record I'm the vice president of
government relations with the New
Hampshire Hospital Association
representing all of the state's 26
hospitals um the hospital Association
has concerns uh about removing the
Department's access to specific
identifiable information uh for the
reasons outlined by the speakers uh that
came before for me specifically I just
want to note um the bill would prevent
the department from coordinating health
related birth and pregnancy information
that support several Federal
designations uh including health
professional shortage areas medically
underserved populations and maternity
care target areas by not being able to
identify those areas it would be
difficult to serve those areas with the
programs that the department can offer
um and so uh we're concerned about the
risk to our federally qualified Health
Center Partners as well as things like
um the student loan repayment programs
for healthcare workers in various
designations um and so for these reasons
among others outlined Again by others
that have spoken before me uh we can't
support HP 1689 thank you for your time
thank you any questions represent
Manu thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question currently the
hospital H all 26 hospitals have
electronic medical record right EMR
system yes they've made major
Investments and electronic medical
records thank
you okay other questions seeing none
thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on House Bill
1689 all right then I'm going to
close
uh I think we got him
started okay I'm going to close public
hearing this bill will be going to
representative grota subcommittee and
I'm opening the hearing on House Bill
1454 and I don't see representative M
Williams there you are okay good thank
you you're up
thank
you
good
for
thank you very much chair McGuire uh
members of the committee it's a pleasure
to be here my name is representative
Rebecca McWilliams I represent South
conquered um and you are sitting within
one of my districts so it's a pleasure
to host you at the lob um I'm here to
present House Bill 1454 I'm the prime
sponsor obviously I'm in support of this
bill um I've passed out an amendment to
this bill um with a little bit of a
tweak to the amendment so an amendment
to the amendment and I just want to be
very clear that there are two major
changes with the amendment uh that are
different than the bill as introduced uh
so if you take a look at the amendment
that I handed out um the intention of
this amendment which changes the
original bill um is that we really want
to be sure that child care providers are
able to opt in to State health and
dental benefits and the intent of this
amendment is that the state will cover
the cost not the child care provider so
uh there was reference on lines 89 and
10 to the child care provider actually
reimbursing the state that is not the
intent of this amendment so that is
stricken in red just to be clear um and
we're referencing Amendment 2024
0184 um uh so that's been passed out
I've also emailed that to everyone uh
the email doesn't have these lines
stricken but the intent once again is
that the child care providers are opting
into state benefits and they are not um
on the hook to pay for them the state
would pay for it um in addition the
change with this amendment which is
different than the bill as introduced is
that um the effective date is January 1
2026 which puts us two years ahead um
and allows us to have a fiscal year
right we would have a budget year to
address financing for this program so uh
the intent here is that we have enough
time uh to figure out cost and figure
out how to find the money for the cost
uh there's a placeholder on line 19 of
the
amendment uh the sum of $1 is
appropriated to Department of
administrative services and obviously $1
is not enough it's a placeholder um so
with that let me just give you a little
bit more background about how we got
where we are and um the proposal for
this bill so as as you may be very aware
um New Hampshire is in the midst of a
child care emergency um parents can't
work when they can't access Child Care
um and I I would say you've probably
heard this from all of your constituents
I'm not going to go in depth about it
there are people after me who will
testify to personal stories um but
obviously we have a situation where we
have people who absolutely could be
involved in the workforce but are unable
to because they can't get child care for
um a child who's not of school age yet
um it's become untenable as a business
model for a child care facility to pay
staff a competitive wage with
Benefits turnover is high and no there
is no Financial way to retain quality
staff meaning they reach a certain level
and they realize they can make more
money in a different business doing
something else and they can no longer
work for Love Alone they need to
actually get a job that pays the amount
of money they need to live in New
Hampshire this also puts New Hampshire
Children at Risk because the people who
are the most experienced and have the
most expert in child care in New
Hampshire end up being the ones who have
to leave and turn over um and therefore
the business model itself is constantly
recruiting new Young inexperienced folks
to work in a child care facility and
then when they become experienced they
move on um to meet the needs of New
Hampshire residents we should be
treating child care and education as a
quasi Public Service rather than a
private business in order to meet our
needs this bill shifts the burden of
health and dental benefits to the state
rather than the child care facility
allowing this quasi public private
business model as shifted with this uh
Bill to at least cover a portion of
those benefits so that the facility can
focus on wages and that employees can
stay because they have the benefits um
so with that I'm happy to answer
questions about this bill um and there
are certainly plenty of people after me
who are going to testify on some nuances
and specifics of the business business
um but I'm happy to take questions thank
you are there questions representative
Dolan and then laus thank you madam
chair uh thank you for uh testify your
testimony and taking my question now if
the child represen you're need to be
closer to your mic
sorry if if the child care provider is
now not going to reimburse the state who
will reimburse the
state
nobody the the intent is for an
appropriation to be made to cover this
from State funds so taxpayer dollars
taxpayers taxpayer dollars yes um okay
thank you representative laus thank you
and I uh this is for you but maybe the
chair can answer I
um you know I think before the committee
can vote to support this they need some
idea of the cost is there going to be a
fiscal note can there be a fiscal note
there is a fiscal well there is oh but
on the on the amendment though which is
the one that's going to
be uh the next speaker is commissioner
Arling house who will probably have some
clue as to the costs okay thank you any
other questions for representative MC
Williams representative
Brown uh thank you madam chair it it's
still true I believe that state
employees pay for a portion of their
benefits their health care
benefits
I can't answer that I think it depends
on the department and the way it's set
up uh having having been one I I believe
that is the case so this would give
these people a better benefit package
than a state employee if I'm seeing it
correctly I can't speak to that
unfortunately okay I think there's repr
simman thank you madam chair um just
thinking about this from a practical
standpoint um
it seems like what you're doing here is
a hybrid between State and private
business is that correct yes in that
case did you give any consideration to
the idea of having a limit to the
profitability of the private business in
order to qualify for the program so if a
I mean I know it's not likely but if a
child care facility was making a million
dollars in profit a year why should we
extend state health benefits to them as
opposed to somebody who's maybe making
20,00 a year and barely scraping
by
um that's a difficult question to answer
because um based on my experience in the
last six years in the legislature and
studying this pretty extensively having
a study committee on the business of
child care um in
2018 um it doesn't appear that any
facilities are making a significant
profit to the extent that um you know
the the CEO is able
to live a lavish lifestyle um this is
not that kind of a business
so having it means tested um could
probably be something like on the very
outside I would be concerned about
embezzlement if that's what's going on
um but it could be on the very outside
and I'm not against guard rails for this
bill uh but I would say the vast
majority of child care facilities in New
Hampshire are doing this out of love and
out of the love for children and many
many of the owners of child care
facilities are not business majors don't
really understand the business side and
when they have some small amount of
training or certificate program they
have a better sense of how to handle and
stay in business but they're still not
reaching that level of extreme
profitability
follow so once again with the with the
complexity of a hybrid model um if the
state is going to put forward
significant resource ources because it
is a significant cost per person
um do we run the risk of the state
essentially absorbing all of the child
care facilities under its umbrella and
then becomes a state-run program um does
the state have any say at that point in
what must happen or must not happen at
each individual Child Care Facility
because they are receiving significant
resources or with the child care
facilities from your perspective still
be able to do pretty much whatever they
want regardless so we run into once
again issues that we always run into in
these scenarios um religious religiously
organized Child Care Facilities versus
you know the whole RI
ofo um so this is a very clear
delineation where we're just talking
about benefits being provided by the
state and to be super clear benefits is
not a common perk for employees of a
child care facility so this is really a
carrot to say um you're a recent High
School grad you're working at a child
care facility understand that this
position has never had benefits before
and now we're in the op in the position
to offer you benefits because it's state
covered um so it's adding a new layer of
a reason for people to stay in
employment and stay in the child care
field as a career rather than as a
starter and then move on elsewhere once
they've gained valuable experience and
can't keep that institutional knowledge
nonetheless um if we're just talking
about benefits and wanting to have
strings attached with the benefits I
understand that you have some concerns
about
um a facility uh I don't know acting
poorly or acting badly and wanting some
kind of uh a test um there really is no
designation between religious and
non-religious Child Care Facility I
don't see the state needing to add some
overlay on that um it really is a public
private partnership that we're talking
about um so similar to how we're doing
education Freedom accounts right now
where we take taxpayer dollars and we
send it with the student wherever they
choose to attend school I would say that
this is benefits for a facility
regardless of their background whether
they are religious or a nonprofit or um
you know just a mom and pop that's
taking six children um and have one
assistant so that would be three staff
you know that's sort of a situation um I
I'm not sure what kind of tests you
would be looking for on the state side
to make sure that they're um qualified
to receive
benefits so uh as I would see it the
difference between this and an education
Freedom account is specifically that
we're giving money to the child and the
child's family and then the child can
choose to spend those funds wherever
they see fit uh funds would not be going
to the family to offer to the um Child
Care Facility in order to provide uh
these this perk it would be going
directly to the child care facility
itself uh which is I believe still with
it's it's it's a fundamental difference
in in constitutional law as far as I
know at the moment um so yeah that would
I I would just for clarification
purposes oh thank you for the
clarification representative
Simon thank you representative
Bara thank you good morning so what
would prevent other licensed Health Care
Providers let's say from would this not
set presidence for other licensed
Healthcare Prov providers for the State
of New Hampshire to also participate in
this Healthcare program most to keep
them
from from
joining I'm not sure I understand the
question this is allowing Child Care
Facilities to opt into to state benefits
paid for by the state um if they were to
choose private insurance or go elsewhere
that would be on them and they would be
paying for that out of pocket rather
than and often they do I'm not saying
nobody does this I'm just saying it's
not that common and so for staff
retention being able to offer benefits
is is a huge way to keep people on
followup follow up but you're setting AE
we we would be you are not but we would
be setting a precedent and then
therefore why would what would prevent
other licensed individuals from New
Hampshire who are in similar situations
as child care providers home health care
agencies for example right or you know
Health agencies in the North Country mhm
you know so what would prevent those
individuals from seeking entry into this
system once we allow
this so I can see your your concern
about a slippery slope right we open the
gate and then everyone wants in I just I
just want to say something it's not a
slippery slope so I don't I I that
argument is I'm sorry but that's a Hut
button for me because that to me is
means nothing okay this sets of
Precedence and so it would would allow
other individuals it is not a slippery
slope that argument should not be used
in legislation or by legislators thank
you um sorry about thank you
clarification so to respond to your
concerns about um home health aids also
opting in to benefits paid for by the
state or other um industries that are
having difficulty retaining staff um and
doing what we know they need to do in
order for us to have a very productive
and successful state
um I would say that that is our job as
legislators to determine what our future
policy is for the state um how we intend
to retain young families and keep them
in the State uh and on this on the other
end of the spectrum how we intend to
keep Elders in the state right there is
a real concern that if you can't get the
health care you need you may need to
leave the state right um so on either
side we set the policy as legislators
and we decide um what is and is not
worthy of receiving a subsidy from the
state so that we can set the policy for
the next 10 years I would posit that
this is an emergency situation for child
care we are not able as a state to
maintain the level of child care that we
need to keep young families here in the
state we know it it's a we have long
long waiting lists for the existing
child care facilities and so we're
looking for Creative Solutions to
maintain staff and attract staff um
Quality staff so that we can provide
that support that families need for kids
in the state I don't know the situation
with home health aids I'm not familiar
with um what the economics are of that
business in New Hampshire so I'm sorry
that I can't really give you the
comparison uh but I would say that if
you have someone who comes forward if
this is signed if you have someone who
comes forward next year with a bill
about home health aids it would be a
very different debate about the
economics of the situation and you know
we as legislators would make that
call thank you other
questions yes rever
Gard thank you madam
chair just quick questions on the is
there I didn't see it maybe you're
missing something but employee limits
could this be a single soul
proprietorship that could operate and
and acquire this benefit or would there
have to be a certain amount of employees
no there's no limit it could be one
person it could be 20 people there's no
limit okay thank you right thank you for
the representative manuti thank you
madam chair a quick question in terms of
basically you're trying to expand the
State Insurance Madam chair could could
you we have her speak up I can't hear
you we can't hear you very
well um basically you're trying to
expand the
self-insured State
Insurance
Group by adding more people to
it yes this would add additional
childcare employees to the state
benefits provided to State Employees we
would be adding additional people to
that
group
okay of Gard yeah I have one more
question just I'm done okay um the
majority of people that work in the
child care facility are much younger
correct no uh it's it's a wide range of
Ages I would say that they're generally
female but there's a wide range of Ages
of people who work in child care all
right thank
you
okay thank you very much for your uh
testimony u i call director Arling house
commissioner Arling
sorry can I have Joyce come with me oh
sure thank you uh I'm Charlie Arling
housee I'm the commissioner of the
Department of administrative services
and you are Joyce Pitman the director of
risk and benefits so uh and we're here
to to oppose the bill and it has nothing
to do with child care care or who wants
the bill or what they want it for or
anything like that I think Child Care is
a wonderful thing I believe children are
a future Etc um it's uh historically so
the department of administrative
Services um through the division of risk
and benefits runs the state employee
health plan we run one Health Plan we
have 15 unions that bargain different
contracts but we have one Health Plan
historically over over uh for longer
than 10 years um before I was
commissioner before Joyce was director
under multiple governors of multiple
parties um the department has has
opposed similar legislation to this not
because we we uh and it has nothing to
do with it whether it's a health care or
a chamber of commerce or anyone else we
run one Health Plan for state employees
that's what we do we don't we don't have
some people in some people out we don't
run multiple plans we uh we have one
Health Plan um historically we've
thought that um and the general position
has been that um if you're going to
Define who's in the health plan or not
you should have a uh a general criteria
for who can come in the health plan what
we would hate to see is that every year
there's a bill for this year it's Child
Care next year it's the Chamber of
Commerce the year after it's home health
care agencies it's somebody all of who
are whom are noble groups of people
doing great work and we have a much
richer health benefit than than anybody
else has a much more expensive health
benefit than anybody else has and so um
so people would naturally want to become
part of it and one year it'll be this
group that that um the committee thinks
is wonderful this year and then you know
an election intervenes and there's a new
group of people sitting at this table
although a lot of the same ones one
would hope um and there's a and there's
another group that that's favored if you
did something I think it should be
criteria based but we run a healthc care
plan for state employees we communicate
unate to health to State Employees we
charge state employees and you might say
aren't there some other people who are
in the
plan not really legislators are in the
plan who pay the entire Freight of their
cost but the argument there is that
they're kind of like state employees
they're legislators um there are a
couple of groups that used to be state
employees cdfa which is sort of a quasi
state agency they were state employees
they were on the health plan when they
became not exactly state employees they
still on the health plan last year um
and I think we're going to see a flurry
of activity because of this the public
defender was added to the list the
public defender was added to the list
not New Hampshire legal aid not Casa not
people who do noble things um to the
benefit of of uh people who need defense
but the public defender program um the
argument for that at the time was that
the public defender program is
functionally a state agency that they
are they receive their their income is
100% a grant from the state in 48 or 49
states it is an agency state government
here we kind of sort of pretend it isn't
and and they come in they do come in
under the basis uh uh where they pay the
premium cost and and the premium cost
and I can get you exact numbers I
actually have exact numbers but the way
to think about it we have a we have a
charge that we charge both the agency
and the employee every empy employee
pays a share it's a collectively
bargained share and it's not very large
but they pay a small bit it's it's
functionally 11,000 for a single 22,000
for a TW member plan and 35,000 for a
family plan those are rounded numbers
but they're pretty close to that um I
say that because people are always a
little bit surprised by that and and
periodically they will say oh you know
what we want we would like to both be
part of the plan and and can can we work
at a lower rate or can you have a a less
Rich benefit for us and and I want to
say there's some threshold things and
we're happy to work with the committee
if you go down this route there's a lot
of stuff we'd want to work with you on
technically we really hope you don't go
down this route but uh some of the
wording in the bill some of the language
in the bill some of the things it refers
to that well that's not what we call
that and things like that um but um they
pay for that well if you've bought
health insurance um um and I have a much
better benefit than I did before I
worked for the state um but it was a lot
cheaper the old one I mean right now it
it is actually cheaper because the
taxpayers are paying my my benefit but
um but I also had a $10,000 deductible
you know in my in my old plan but
generally speaking we offer a plan and
we offer it to State Employees and and
we want for the future for that to still
be the case and not um and not
periodically every year for there to be
another group of people added and
another group of people added and and
and it's not it's not that I think the
state shouldn't do something to help
people in the child care industry and
it's certainly not the position of the
department um or the or past governors
or the current governor um but it's you
know in for administrations of varying
parties for example this has this has
been the position and it's because of uh
uh administratively and that you know
you don't want to add some people this
year some people this year some people
this year and when you do add people
they have to all be
in that's the other thing and like the
public defender program public defender
program is in they're not in if they
want to be in they don't kind of get to
be in all of them are in you're in
period because that you we we don't want
adverse selection where just the people
who need knee surgery are getting in and
they're going to get out in two years
and things like that and so but we're
just generally opposed to this that's
most of it yeah but also happy to answer
any technical questions people
have thank
you representative Shu and then man buy
thank you madam chair good morning nice
to see you both again uh could you
explain please for the pertinence of
this bill and probably for some of the
newer members of this committee the
limits to the amounts that you use to
purchase the health care
plan the um oh I think I I think I do
know what you're asking that and and I
want to separate out retiree Health
which is limited by the state budget um
and the the state of New Hampshire
health benefit is a self-insured plan we
don't buy an insurance policy and since
about 2002 I think three I guess um we
don't buy a insurance policy we we pay
the premiums um but there well no there
isn't a
limit so I mean functionally that that
you know
we uh you're qualified for certain
benefits and if you use them if next
year 10,000 people got knee surgery we
have about 27,000 members if 10,000
people got knee surgery we would pay
10,000 knee surgeries and if 2,000
people got knee surgery we' paid 2,000
knee surgeries and you know the rates
and things like that are negotiated
through um our third party
administrator a followup followup and
and the rates would increase if the
expenses go up for those
participating yes thank you represent
man
py thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question commissioner um are
foster care providers eligible to
participate like the legislators
have no pay into no no one is eligible
to participate except um state employees
and that then the the caveats to that if
you want to call it that are legislators
and now the public defender program
that's
it they I mean nhrs is in because they
started in there's employ employees at
P's who are we can argue about whether
the state employees or not but but it
dates to when they were in and and cdfa
but those are the people who are
eligible yes yes repres gold thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question which is really more just a
reinforcement I'd like you to reinforce
you answered my question about the
public defenders and I recall that um
that process we went through last year
very clearly and so for the new members
of our committee just wanting you to
once again clarify
what set them apart from um from any
other entity and and as I recall it and
please correct me if I'm wrong it was
that they operate under contract they do
a necessary um process for the state
that all other states have as a state
agency but New Hampshire chooses to
contract with only one agency is that
correct I I think that's a that's a good
description it's a constitutionally
required function that the state is
Contracting with an entity that and I
think one of the important pieces
is we're not Contracting with a vendor
it is an entity that does nothing else
it is an entity that raises no other
money it's an entity whose entire budget
is granted them by the state and I mean
they're functionally part of judicial
Council they just happen to sort of not
be and it is it is probably the only
thing in the entire state that you could
refer to as a as functionally a state
agency that it's a kind of weird thing
that it's like that and I'm not I don't
know why it's like that so maybe it
makes all the sense in the world
although it just outside looking and it
seems weird but that's
why thank
you represent flus uh thank you so just
a couple questions on interpreting this
one is um as I understand this would
have the state pay the entire cost which
uh it appears to me would be actually a
better benefit than anybody else in the
system
gets I if that's true and the other one
is um you know what what are the
problems with the thing where it looks
like a child care the company the
employer can opt in or not opt out or
not every two years make that decision
is that going to cause problems I the
the extent to which uh the extent to
which small subgroups of of uh people
can opt in and out of plans um is the
greater the frequency the worse it is
two years is better than one year four
years is better than two years um opting
opting in or opting out it it it's best
if you know it certainly shouldn't be
the individual because that be it leads
to all sorts of adverse selection issues
that that becomes an issue in terms of a
so the amendment would technically the
way it's written I don't know if this is
the intention but would technically
provide a better benefit we have a we
have a small co-pay um for uh for state
employees um we certainly don't pay 100%
of anybody um at at some point although
I'm I'm sure the sponsors of the bill
would say well we would accept the terms
of the co-pay or whatever um but um the
notion of if you if you think about you
know State reps are allowed to join you
you you have to
pay 1122 or 35
and if you if you did go down this path
somebody would have to pay that like
there's nobody right now what happens is
it's not in Joyce's budget we it's in
every it's in every agency's budget it's
in the Personnel lines it's a it's a
class 60 expense if you're reading the
budget and so everybody who's in there's
a there's a transfer every pay period
that goes into out of the state budget
into into a separate thing which happens
to be called fund 60 and so you'd have
to figure out I'm not saying that
couldn't be done anything can be done
you'd have to figure it out but
somewhere in the state budget would sit
the totality of the Grant and it would
it would have to sit somewhere in the
budget it wouldn't just sort of sort of
be spent it would have to sit somewhere
followup follow up I I know you may not
have the actual numbers but can do you
have or can you come up with a just even
a very rough estimate of what this would
cost I if if somebody to if somebody
told me how many people would be joining
and how many of them would be single how
many of them would be double and how
many would be family yeah easily but I
would need that number like I I don't
honestly know not having read all the
childcare reports if we're talking about
a thousand people or 4,000 people and
and how many of them are likely to need
family coverage okay thank
you
questions all right thank thank you very
much
commissioner Jackie
Cowell
good morning how do you do my name is
Jackie Cowell good morning Madame chair
and members of the committee my name is
Jackie Cowell um I am the executive
director of uh Early Learning New
Hampshire we are a Statewide nonprofit
that works on childcare issues and so
I'm here today to urge you to support
this bill and tell you why I think it
should be supported um
in in New Hampshire today there's always
a lot of you you know it is a noble
thank you for saying that commissioner
um it is a noble and um career um but
it's also a very important career to our
economy and so the what we've learned
you know is that for you know every
there's a there's a childcare Workforce
crisis but there is in every industry
almost every industry today in New
Hampshire because of lots of different
reasons you all know them um is facing a
Workforce crisis Child Care businesses
are no different what is different is
that um child care employs what we call
the workforce behind the workforce when
a teacher resigns as many as eight
children on average will not have child
care which means their parents then may
have to leave the labor force there's a
real direct connection between the
people working in child care and then
who in all other Industries are able to
actually work or not we're also finding
that prior to the pandemic we have fewer
opportunities fewer slots a child care
center for instance um may have been
running for years decades with 10
classrooms they're now running with nine
or eight be you know because they cannot
find people to do this work so this
particular bill is designed to be a very
specific Bill to support the workforce
behind the workforce to allow our labor
force to go to work and so what we're
learning again is that um you know these
class rooms they're still there but they
were all they've been running for
decades but they haven't been running
for a few years now because they can't
find the people we want to retain the
people and your good question about the
ages you know the people that are in the
you know I think what's going to be part
of doing this and having it come next
year with good look at what is the size
of it's 5,500 people is what the
estimate is right now how old they are
whether they have spouses and families
or two people that has not been studied
but that can be part of what we look at
to determine what it would cost but also
to to talk together about the criteria
of why why this Workforce why would you
do that for this Workforce there are
nonprofit childcare programs there are
privately owned Child Care programs we
you know the the technical could be
for-profit but um representative Simon
there aren't too many out there making a
million dollars I know you know that but
interesting criteria that you mentioned
you know so that you don't want people
who could afford it to just take it I
get that but um um I've no many Child
Care owners today they they they own it
it's a it's a privately owned business
um they haven't been taken salary for
about two years um because the math just
doesn't work when you give people
benefits When when you pay their wages
where is the number one place you're
going to find that Revenue it's the
Working Families it's the tuition that
the Working Families are paying we all
know it's tough to pay it already let
alone if we give them more health
insurance it's going to come have to
come from the work hardworking families
and so that's why this bill is really
proposing at looking at this being a a
public private partnership because Child
Care supports all Industries and all
labor the labor force in New Hampshire
and and um we're not just you know
supporting today's Workforce childcare
helps prepare the workforce of the
future of course the children that are
in there so um a child care you know
provider right now a teacher going to
work will stop at McDonald's and she's
going to make she's probably been in the
field for about five years and is making
about
1315 an hour after all that time she
drives up to McDonald's and she's the
big sign $18 an hour to start and we're
going to pay your health benefits we're
going to send you to school you know so
it's harder and harder to stay in the
field and it's harder and harder to
recruit so I I urge you to support this
bill to keep it um ought you have it
ought to pass so we can have that
discussion we can do those studies we
can really look at what the cost would
be and the why together thank you thank
you are there any
questions repr Simon thank you madam
chair thank you for your testimony um
from your perspective you're saying um
an average uh childcare worker is making
13 to 15 and they see the sign at
McDonald's for $18 to $20 an hour um so
from your perspective even in the
disparity and the pay gap having this
particular health insurance would close
the gap for people who would typically
be in that field I think it would really
help them stay I think it would really
help them come to the field I do yeah
thank you
yeah I if I may yes um I I did just
looked right before this there were some
other people coming to testify um they
couldn't get out because there weren't
enough staff but uh online you will see
um there's right now I believe about 536
people who did uh right in in their
support thank you thank you for that
information I don't see any other
question so thank you is there anyone
else who wishes to testify on House Bill
1454 see any so I will close the hearing
and open the hearing on House Bill
1546 is representative Corker in
here ah okay thank
you
I don't see
any representative corkran Hillsboro 44
um my testimony on this bill is fairly
simple it is uh unreasonable to um ask a
taxpayer to support uh not only uh
attitudes but active discrimination
against his own category um it is
everyone's right as an individual to
make their own purchasing decisions and
you know if uh someone is a hardcore
rtist and they dislike Ben and Jerry's
political stances they don't have to buy
Ben and Jerry ice cream if someone is a
uh left of center they can choose to buy
their groceries from an organic bakery
or whatever but when it comes to
government purchasing things on our
behalf uh we lose this right um it is
illegal uh both at state level and at
Federal level to discriminate on the
basis of certain categories race
religion Etc but as we all know this
happens all the time there's certain
approved directions and unapproved
directions this bill uh simply forbids
state and town governments from
purchasing from corporations that
practice active discrimination on race
and sex um I think that there are two U
protests against this bill we don't need
it because it doesn't happen in which
case I would say then once the uh you
know if the bill were to be enacted in
law uh we would see no activity there
would be no cases where anyone would
find uh that the state where towns were
purchasing um from organizations that
were engaged in discrimination uh and
the other one you know there's a joke
online it's not happening and it's good
that it is uh so you know if the
objection is well you know this is going
to create new court cases because people
are going to be bringing challenges
under this I would say you know that's
sort of like saying we shouldn't pass a
law against arson because it's going to
increase the demand on our police and
courts U that's the entirety of my
testimony and happy to answer questions
good thank you I I have a a question and
then Representative Patrick so you said
that this discrimination is
illegal yes right thank you
representative Fitzpatrick thank you
madam chair how would you
know how would I know yeah what's your
what's your
criteria for for stating that it's
illegal currently for saying that anyone
is meeting whatever criteria you're you
want to create
to not purchase from um you know I think
that in general uh the courts find it
you know quite easy to you know uh
enforce their own Rules of Evidence uh
and in this case we go into some data uh
or some specific examples of what would
be included so if for example uh someone
said you know the state is purchasing um
you know snowplows from you know the uh
snowplow Corporation of Saskatchewan and
the snowplow Corporation of Saskatchewan
says you know we proudly
uh you know promote people of certain
races and certain Sexes um you know uh
regardless of their capabilities or you
know to the detriment because we're not
looking at individual skills and it is
unfortunately the case that lots of
Corporations practice this and proudly
brag about
it thank you madam
chair all right thank you very much
representative
Brown thank you madam chair I have a a
couple if I
might um a line six uh excuse me line
eight
yes can you clarify for me I I
understand the beginning of the
statement that they we shall not
contract for a company that
discriminates and hiring uh Etc through
line
8 including but limited to permitting
Dei statements so are do you know are
Dei statements included in the law
similarly to the Discrimination
statements about sex race sexuality and
national origin Etc the intent of the
bill as written is that uh Dei
statements uh as part of a corporate
policy would serve as evidence that the
corporation is engaged in
discrimination so I think that's a no to
my
question yes thank you yeah uh followup
or additional
question in on line 16 and
17 would this be that you're guilty
until proven
innocent uh no I believe that's
incorrect um line 14 and 15 uh says that
the uh citizen or the Attorney General
shall have the burden uh to prove it and
if they have proven it um this is sort
of a reverse the um you know if the
citizen has proven primashe evidence
that uh this discrimination exists that
the uh Corporation or excuse me the uh
purchasing uh body you know a town or
the state uh could you know use the uh
procedure in 16 and 17 to say you know
you made a good showing but you missed
some details we're going to show why
actually that's incorrect okay thank you
and may I one more one more having thank
you madam chair having
been a state employee and done more
contracts than I would like to
remember there there were cases in my
history where you would go to a vendor
and they would say it's just too hard to
do the state contract we're not going to
put in a quote and and that's not an
unusual because it's a much more
complicated process Than A
Private Industry do you see that this
additional piece would make that happen
more often that companies we would be
the state would not have access to as
many reasonable quotes as you might get
otherwise I I do understand the question
it's a good question um I have two
responses uh one is that I think that
New Hampshire's uh purchasing is uh much
less um wrapped in requirements than
certain other states um and so you know
if uh the state of California or the
state of New York you know walk in with
their 700 page you know standard
contract um you know corporate and and
you know I've done purchasing I've been
on the other side of as small vendor
trying to sell into places um you know
corporations tend to sort themselves as
yes we're in the business of supplying
pickup trucks to government's and here
are our 900 pages of answers um I don't
think that this would add appreciably uh
the second answer is I think that it's
you know quite simple for a corporation
to say uh you know yes we sell snowplows
and no we certainly don't discriminate
on Race because it's illegal under
federal law to do so so you know I'd be
happy to sign a Post-It not note to that
effect it's very simple uh thank you
thank you madam chair appreciate that
okay
questions
faart looking at the looking at the
fiscal note yes second to last page
second paragraph the Department of
Justice States this bill could impact
thousands of contracts across the state
counties municipalities potentially
leading to a surge in complaints managed
by the Attorney General's
office screening for compliance might
become essential for State contracts
demanding increased time in resources
but this is already illegal isn't that
their job to is my understanding
yes
yes that's the usual sort of thing the
Department of Justice says you're making
something more of a crime therefore it's
possible it might cause more costs in
the court system the and and I would say
you know I sort of pre- address this
with I I do see one or two objections uh
and you know this objection is you know
wait we can't pass this bill if we had a
bill like this we would no longer be
allowed to buy from the anti-chinese uh
you know steering wheel Corporation of
Nebraska um uh if it turned out to be
the case that you know people are saying
hey uh did you know that you are
purchasing you know heating fuel from a
corporation you know that discriminates
on the race of such and such uh I I
would think that uh that would be an
enforcement action that we would be
happy to take represent
laus uh my question is if if this
activity is already illegal uh why not
deal with it you know you know go after
the company for doing that rather than
burdening every single Department in the
state that's going to be doing
procurement with trying to vet all these
companies I mean that's not really you
know the function of the department
they're trying to plow snow or whatever
um but I mean there are aren't there
paths to go after discrimination as it's
that is a good question um and my answer
to that is twofold on the first hand we
all understand the distinction between a
uh Criminal case and a civil case um and
so you know all of the time uh an
attorney general will say you know I
know something's going on here but this
isn't a you know Department priority I'm
going to have to jump through so many
Hoops I'm going to have to prove Beyond
a reasonable doubt that this guy uh you
know threw a pack of cigarettes out the
window you know it's not going to happen
uh and with civil cases there is uh a
lower bar although you know not trivial
the second one is that um you know I
could walk into the Attorney General's
office right now and uh say that you
know I have clear and convincing
evidence that um the state of New
Hampshire is purchasing you know $15
million of such and such and that uh
firm has a explicit policy right on
their web page that we discriminate
against you know certain category and
the attorney general who is you know not
uh and and this isn't a criticism it's
just a statement of how things are
organized he is not responsible to the
voters uh he can say you know I hear
what you're saying that's not my
priority um and yet as a individual
voter and taxpayer I still say well you
know I am paying uh taxes every day that
you know um go in and it's going to you
know imagine that I have a
Asian-American wife uh I'm paying taxes
to a firm that explicitly discriminates
against asian-americans and you know I'm
not going to say that that's exactly
compelled speech but it has a flavor
similar to compelled speech I'm being
compelled to expend you know the uh the
fruits of my labor uh to engage in an
activity albeit indirectly that you know
I find repugnant uh so by having a right
of private action this is distinct from
existing uh laws thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you for your time uh the
chair will call uh David
jovit thank you thank you Mr chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dave juv I a senior vice
president for public policy for the
business and industry Association I'm
not before this committee very often so
for those of you who are not familiar
with the Bia we serve as New Hampshire's
Statewide Chamber of Commerce we have
approximately 400 employer members who
are providing employment to over a
100,000 Granite Staters we're here in
opposition to this
bill and I'll Focus my comments on
line8 where it starts out talking about
um discrimination on the basis of sex
race sexuality national origin ethnicity
or
ideology which I think we could probably
all agree to and which are commonly
understood um issues of discrimination
that are covered under law but then it
adds but not limited to permitting
diversity equity and inclusion
statements for the employers who have
statements which may be worded in 10,000
different ways I think they would take
exception to and probably be offended by
the suggestion that that equates to
discrimination uh so we would oppose the
bill just based on that you're um this
is essentially this
bill is the state of New Hampshire
telling private sector employers what
they think they should do or shouldn't
do in the best interest of their
employees and customers and I don't
think that's
right I also think it will could lead
to extraordinarily increased litigation
that employers uh may be able to quickly
dispense with but at some cost and I
question the very premise of the bill as
it was presented which is why should
citizens of New Hampshire have their
taxpayer money sent to companies that
have diversity equity and inclusion
statements I would
ask if only their opinion counts why
aren't we considering the citizens of
the state who would like their tax money
directed to companies that have
diversity equity and inclusion
statements the fact is you're just
opening up a can of worms which is bad
enough but we this to go forward it is
essentially the state of New Hampshire
saying if you're a company that for
whatever reason you choose to have
diversity equity and inclusion
statements is a part of your uh business
you're not welcome in this state and I
think that's not a good place for New
Hampshire to be happy to answer any
questions representative
Shu thank you madam chair thank you very
much for your
testimony uh could you give us an idea
how complicated and time consuming it
might be for these entities to
investigate the companies that they do
business with for meeting these um
criteria I I don't even begin to
understand how this bill would be
enforceable and how the various entities
of state county and local governments
would assess whether a company's uh
diversity equity and inclusion statement
is synonymous with discrimination I just
don't even know how that is
possible other
questions thank you very much thank
you jamus
Monahan
good morning representative McGuire
members of the committee um I'm Jim
Monahan with the DuPont group I'm here
today on behalf of series uh sustainable
AG advocacy organization that works with
some of the largest businesses and
investors in
and across the country to build a more
sustainable global economy I've passed
in written testimony and we'll file it
electronically as well there are some
links in the testimony uh that'll
provide you additional information about
uh Series in our um in Our member
companies um but uh for example active
members with the organization in
Hampshire include Autodesk Timberland
Stony field wor than Industries uh as
well as over 200 uh smaller businesses
that have signed on to to a series of
policy principles which outline the
benefits of investing in clean energy
and uh Energy Efficiency um we share the
concerns of uh the Bia and others who
have spoken that uh the provisions in
this bill that address diversity equity
and inclusion statements are misplaced
um it seems to equate that activity
which is incredibly common uh in
businesses in New Hampshire and and
across the country to have diversity
Equity inclusion statements as somehow
being unlawfully discriminatory when in
fact those who adopt them probably see
it as the opposite um and so it's for
those reasons that siries opposes House
Bill
1564 um an act relative to government
purchasing that would prevent the state
from Contracting with businesses that
devop adopt diversity equity and
inclusion statements um businesses and
act thei policy not only because it's a
moral imperative to create more
welcoming workspace be but because
because it's a strategic necessity that
forers Innovation uh drives economic
growth and ensures long-term corporate
success um a study which is LinkedIn the
testimony we provide you by series
member LinkedIn finds that companies
with Dei teams um uh were 22% more
likely to be seen as an industry-leading
company with high high caliber uh Talent
uh we'd also add an an echo from a
procurement p uh um uh provision that
adopting uh this this provision and the
prohibition on companies participating
and purchasing the state county and
local level that have de Dei statements
would probably be quite costly uh to
government New Hampshire because it will
greatly diminish the number of uh folks
that bid um on uh on rfps and
opportunities to do business with the
state um I'll leave with that I'll
answer any questions you all might have
but as I said the testimony we're
passing out and which will be sent to
you electronically does include links to
additional information about series and
our policy
principles thank you are there
questions no there were not enough
copies for the entire committee I
thought I had passed in 22 copies but I
was certainly happy to get them to you
thank you okay we would appreciate
it okay Kate
Horgan
thank you madam chair my name is Kate
Horan I'm here behalf on today of the
New Hampshire Association of counties
the association does oppose this bill uh
and representative Shu hit it right on
the head we have no idea how we would
possibly verify all of the contractors
and uh employer purchasing uh agreements
that we we purchase from this would
eliminate platforms like Amazon because
Amazon is its own company and sells its
own stuff but individual sellers also
participate in that platform and so
while Amazon may qualify under this new
bill as proposed some of the sellers may
not and we may or may not be able to get
a hold of those sellers to verify and if
we even if we are able to the amount of
time that that would take would
drastically slow down purchasing at the
County government level um I will leave
it at that we agree with uh both Mr
Monahan Mr ju's positions um but I'm
happy to take any questions from the
committee
okay I don't see any thank you very much
thank you Katherine
heck
good morning chairman Maguire and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Katherine heck and I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and the 234 cities and towns
in New Hampshire um we oppose this bill
and while we certainly agree that
discrimination has no place in in
contract and purchasing we are deeply
concerned on page two starting with line
19 the prohibitions around cities towns
and unincorporated places how we would
in fact comply with the legislation we
do not have the
information required to evaluate a
company the criteria is not quite clear
to us on what that would look like and
for example the federal government
maintains a database of excluded parties
which would include any company or
contractor disbarred from doing business
with the federal government so in the
absence of a tool like that when you
receive a Federal grant you're required
to look up if anyone you're Contracting
with has been suspended or disbarred BAS
based on criteria set forth by the
federal government um we would not be
able to necessarily comply with this law
is written I did want to add that it was
discussed about rfps and bidding um on
another bill that we were working on
looking at Architects and engineers and
contractors we have um gathered data to
support that last year we received on
average
1.5 bids per project for facilities and
facility infrastructure that we were
trying to do on the municipal level in
2018 we were receiving 3.86 bids per
project so a bill like this could
seriously um impact our ability to move
forward um local projects but again if
there was some type of clearing house
that was very clear on what the state
requirements were and companies were
prev vetted that might assist us in our
ability to comply with this type of
legislation and that's all I have unless
there's any
questions okay thank you very much are
there
questions thank you seeing none thank
you does anyone else wish to testify on
House Bill
1546 okay seeing none I will close the
public hearing the committee will resume
at
1:15
for
hm
all right good afternoon welcome back I
have a request for those people who use
the computer on my desk in the office
please do not leave your drinks on on
the desk I've today I found a coffee cup
a can of soda and a bottle of water
so I did not pour them out
today don't care
they all right
so our representative
Merchant thank you madam chair uh for
the record my name is Gary Merchant
representative Gary Merchant
representing civan County district 6
which is Claremont in cyen New Hampshire
I'm here today representing both myself
as a representative as a sponsor of this
bill the prime sponsor as well as the
chair of the prescription duug
affordability board so I'm not going to
read my testimony um I think that could
be done uh you folks can do that clearly
on your own but basically speak to the
to the bill and reason them
here in House Bill 2 last year there was
an inserted some changes to RSA 126 BB
which governs the board and one of those
changes was to limit the executive
director to two years after the date of
H and the other one was that which I
believe is unprecedented
that a contract that the board
has has to go to fiscal as well as the
governor and counsel I have not found
anywhere in the state that that
requirement is
required so my concern is by passing
this bill and putting that language in
the
RSA we're setting a
precedent and I think anytime we're
setting a precedent we should be very
careful how we set
it I think it's somewh way Overkill I
think the Govern and Council does a
phenomenal job looking at contracts I
think that's where it should reside not
going to both fiscal as well as the
governor and councel it's redundant and
I don't know the need for it the other
one is a two-year limitation and that
was there because there's an
issue of
redundancy there was an issue about the
redundancy between the board and the
Department of Insurance the insurance
department that study is being done it's
ongoing however that will not be known
to us in that report until sometime in
October or November of this
year being a legislative body as it is
what I'm asking for is not
to eliminate the 2-year restriction but
to expand it to four years to allow the
legislative process time to work through
the process and do it appropriately and
correctly
and not force ourselves into a situation
both the board and the legislative body
to rush through something that it
probably shouldn't
do so therefore the two elements in the
bill is to modify RSA 126
BB to extend the two years to four
years to
delete the requirement the redundancy
between the board with contracts in
fiscal and governor and Council and by
the way this bill has the full support
of the board including representative
Edwards who was on the meeting uh it's
on tape you can see it so he supported
the bill during the
meeting and I'm just saying the board as
collectively is also in support of the
bill they're not trying to
eliminate the time limit if you will
recognizing we have to get the report on
redundancy and then we have to be able
to act on it all we're asking this
committee to do and the legislative body
to do was provide a reasonable period of
time to act on whatever the
recommendations are from that study and
then at the same time eliminate what I
think is potentially a precedent that we
now want to
set thank you are there any
questions representative
do thank you madam chair um it may sound
like an odd question but in this in this
two-year U cycle does the executive
director have to
campaign um for the reappointment or is
it U you know what's the method of of
getting
reappointed there the method of
reappointment basically they're hired by
the board so they become a state
employee they're not basically um um a
political entity they don't they're not
elected if you will so at that point in
time if after two years if we don't pass
the bill and to extend it then their
employment becomes non-employed now they
can't have a job the job
disappears so thank
you Simon thank you madam chair uh I may
have missed it in your testimony but uh
the two-year cycle for the executive
director where are we at in that cycle
right now
good question represent Simon right now
the way the law was written is two years
from the date of hire the executive
director has been hired his name is Kurt
Williamson he begins on January 29th so
the two years starts from January 29th
of this year follow up follow up so if
you have a full two years you said the
um the report is coming out in October
um what do you foresee that would
require an extra two years of on top of
the year and a quarter that you would
have to review and make your changes
it's the legislative calendar um my
understanding is that if the report
comes out in say beginning of
November the dates in which we have to
file legislation is relatively narrow so
what will happen is we'll get the report
someone's got to look at the report make
the decision to support another bill but
we'll most likely miss that window in
November which means we have to wait
another full year before we can take
legislative action thank
you any others represent leus thank you
um it's been a while since I've looked
at this but as I recall at least as the
statute read I don't know if it's
changed that um money would come to the
board through um certain fees and and
other things charged to I think a
variety of organizations that you know
manufactured distributed all that sort
of thing um and if that's correct and
that money comes directly to the board
and the board could spend it I could see
a I'm just talking about section two
would there be a uh kind of a difference
between what's going on with the board
and certain other things where the board
would be taking in money and spending it
without any kind of legislative approval
and then I could see um you know going
to the uh fiscal committee and general
court is kind of um you know a way to at
least include some legislative oversight
of spending so it doesn't seem to be
quite the same as everything else right
thank you for the question M represent
leas um in House Bill two we eliminated
that completely so in other words the
board is completely dependent upon State
funds there's no fees that the board
assesses um so right now in House Bill 2
it's fully supportive out of the state
general Treasury
which does have legislative oversight it
goes to a budget committee review and it
goes to a legislative review so the
board finances are in fact controlled by
the legislative body um followup follow
up yeah I'm just trying to skim through
it looks like there are some fees are
there still fees and if so do they just
go to the general fund or how's that
work I'm not aware of anywhere there's
any fees those fees were
eliminated um just quick follow I mean
I'm looking at what's in uh on gen Court
under r I don't know if it hasn't been
updated it may not be updated I can get
you a current version of the uh RSA if
you'd like I'd appreciate that if you
would but the uh to your point in House
Bill two um House Bill two eliminated
all the fees because they're considered
to be quote
unconstitutional um and at that point in
time we went to the general court and
the legislative body elected to put
money in the budget through the
legislative process to the financial and
that that's how the board support it
today thank because i' had a concern
about that when it came before us before
thank
you
okay representative sh it thank you
madam chair um looking at the RSA and I
don't see any kind of direction if you
go to fiscal committee and they approve
and then the governor and Council
disapproves if there's a conflict
between those two uh it looks like
there's no guidance as to what you would
do have you encountered anything like
that in the brief period of time that
this has been
in thank you for the question um
representative in a brief period of time
I let me say this we have not had any
real activity with the board until just
recently because we had to wait for the
funding to occur um we have anou with
the Department of Health Human Services
because we're administrative attached to
them but as far as at this point in time
we have not had any issue per se because
we had never had a reason for a contract
so to be
seen okay interesting thank you very
much oh excuse me representative Schmid
has a
question thank you madam
chair so are you aware of any other um
State of New Hampshire agency which uh
has this kind of a funding uh structure
where it's the fiscal committee and the
governor and executive Council
um thank you for the question
representative based upon what little
not little I tried to reach out to
different agencies different boards and
commission I have not found one yet that
has this
requirement my followup so and you've
made a thorough search I take
it I guess the question comes down to
the definition of thorough um I I've
done what I can your colleague
representative I've been your colleague
for about six years now yes I've seen
you in action uh so I think the my word
use of the word thorough is uh well uh
you know fitted to I believe the next
speaker will be able to answer this
question for you okay thank
you without debating the the meaning of
thorough other questions thank you very
much representative mer thank you
representative
leean
good afternoon Madame chair for the
record my name is Peter Lehman I
represent the towns of Peterboro and
sharen excuse me and I'm here to testify
against 16001 FN
a um to be quite candid I'm a little
puzzled
uh that this bill was
introduced um representative Jess
Edwards and I have been following the U
drug uh pres prescription drug
affordability board for some time this
board has appeared before fisal for
requests uh money requests um issues
dealing with rules and the the fiscal
committee has tabled a number of their
requests until some of these questions
had been answered the Lang which you see
in the bill dealing with the section
126 BB colon 11 was specifically added
by uh representative Edwards into the
budget found on page
102 uh this was because of the concerns
that we had on the finance committee and
the fiscal committee um I do serve on
the finance committee and I also serve
on the joint legislative fiscal
committee and for those of you that may
not be familiar with with the joint
legislative fiscal committee there are
five senators and five house members
that look at spending requests or
departments that may run out of money
and we accept uh requests for funding
Federal funding comes through us and we
meet generally once a
month so I'm again a little puzzled um
with the earlier testimony because I've
been texting representative Edwards and
uh he is not in favor of the restrict
removing the section that takes a joint
legislative fiscal committee out of this
review and to representative leak's
thoughts uh we also felt in the finance
committee being a new board that has the
ability to spend an awful lot of money
perhaps it should still have some
legislative oversight thank
you excuse me represent leis do you have
any question any concerns with the
four-year term rather than the twoyear
term for the director or I personally do
not thank you are there any other
questions representative
Shu thank you madam chair I'll I'll ask
the same question that I asked uh
representative Merchant what will the
what should the board do if there's a
conflict between fiscals approval and
say the governor and Council
disapproval how how do they resolve that
generally um a number of issues come
through fiscal first before they go to
governor and councel so it wouldn't be
like governor and Council approving and
then coming to fiscal the general way of
uh things move from fiscal is from
fiscal to the governor and Council and
if we don't approve it it doesn't go to
governor and councel okay what about if
you approve it and they say no I don't
see any remedy to resolve that
difference well if the fiscal committee
was taken out of it um it would just go
straight to government and Council
there'd be no legislative oversight
whatsoever um followup my point though
is um should there be something built
into this as to a
remedy I think um representative Shu the
way it is now is sufficient works well
or we haven't had a problem with it yet
and again this language was established
in House Bill 2 just a little more than
six months ago and hasn't had a chance
to even go through the process thank you
the questions represent black if I may
it's not a question but it's a response
there there's a number of cases where a
legislative committee deals with
something then it goes to governor and
councel for example
jcec um can approve certain things we
approve then it goes to governor and
counsel um and in that case I mean if
the committee approves it and the
governor and councel don't then it stops
it's an it's it has to pass every step
there's no conflict
really yeah good the governor and
Council has different priorities and
different criteria than the legislator
in some
cases okay anyone
else all right thank you for your
testimony thanks Madam chair and thanks
the
committee is there anyone else who
wishes to testify at House Bill
16001 all right seeing none close the
public
hearing and I think we will go into
executive
session and discuss House Bill
1546 on government
purchasing does someone have a
motion for your memory that was the one
just before
lunch what's that representative gold
Madam chair I'd like to move to itl that
bill
second
okay um itl by representative Gold
seconded by representative
Schmidt would you like to speak to your
motion I just think that um as we heard
in the testimony the bill would be very
difficult to
monitor the definitions how do you even
Define the kinds of things it just I and
we heard that the activities that the
the prime sponsor seem to be concerned
with which was illegality of
discrimination um is already against the
law and so this seems redundant and I
think that's about what I have to say
about it representa Schmid do you to
speak to your second thank you madam
chair so the workability was heavily
criticized um in in in the aggregate
anyway uh by the by the people who spoke
in opposition that was all a testimony
except the sponsors um and and and I
agree that it it this is also a solution
in search of a problem so I happy to
support the
itl right any other comments
representative leus I I agree with the
itl um the problem is it's a problematic
precedent I mean arguably almost
anything that's illegal that a vendor
might do could more you know you could
help enforcing it by making it part of
the requirements part of the procurement
process but that's not the right way to
handle it in my
view yes I
would but based on this we could say
well if you've got any wage and ours
discrepancies we can't do business with
you and that would uh that would be
problematic anyone
else comments questions concerns
okay then the motion is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
1546 and the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey
yes representative
Dolan representative
Gard clerk vot
J representative Brown
do we have
yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative Shu
yes representative Fitzpatrick
yes representative Gould
yes representative
Smith yes representative manag py yes
and the chair yes 14 y a zero uh one one
a sorry 14 to one is that right yes 14
to1 okay uh does anyone object to
consent okay well you don't object to
consent I think it we should put it
there uh representative
G uh I will lead your committee report
at your earliest convenience and Absol
abely no later than next Wednesday are
you going to pull it off
cons
yes well if you if you if you want to
object to consent no problem
okay fine all right
and does anybody else have another
motion okay I don't see any volunteers
so what's that rep I I could make a
motion on uh
1454 if you want I'm not ready to make
that okay you're not ready to do it okay
fine all right in that case we will come
out of executive session and our next
hearing is at 2:
p.m.
for
all right welcome to Edna I'm opening
the hearing on House Bill 1486 and I
call the sponsor representative
Gera thank you very much I'd like to CH
thank the chair and the committee uh I
am the primary sponsor of the bill but
I'm going to keep my introductory
remarks very very brief because um we
have a witness who just arrived he is uh
he'll be back in here in a moment uh
professor Charles wheen from from
Dartmouth who is the real person uh that
I think you're going to want to ask your
questions of uh and he has to leave by
245 and drive straight back to Handover
so I'm going to keep my introductory
remarks very very brief uh and then have
Professor wheen come uh and talk to you
and answer your
questions this bill is to establish uh a
proxy carbon price for uh purchases uh
by the the the state St we're talking
about Renovations or the purchase of uh
for example vehicles or other uh
equipment that would involve carbon
emissions it is a proxy price because we
do not currently have a carbon price
here in New Hampshire or in the United
States although as Witnesses who will
follow me will discuss uh it is coming
Canada has one the United sta or uh the
European Union has one uh and we are
going to be at a significant economic
disadvantage if we do not also move in
the direction of carbon prices think it
will hurt our exports uh to those
countries uh those uh those
markets uh this is a a situation I think
where we can walk and chew gum at the
same time we can reduce the burden on
taxpayers and reduce carbon emissions at
the same time uh markets are based on
incentives uh absent incentives uh it is
it is pretty close to the literal
definition of insanity to believe that
someone will uh in a market context
change their behavior we have to have
economic incentives uh and that is the
the policy makers who originally uh came
up with this idea of carbon pricing uh
were conservative market-driven policy
makers uh who were trying to find an
alternative to State driven models uh
and so carbon pricing was about
constructing a a market for
carbon for carbon emissions the state of
New Hampshire is an agent is an actor in
the market as we uh you know uh build
buildings and renovate buildings HVAC
systems and we produce or pardon me we
um we consume vehicles and uh and other
carbon
emitting
uh uh costs right uh that that the
taxpayer has to pay for the purpose of
this bill is actually to be able to
think about how the carbon Market will
allow us to save money for taxpayers of
the State of New Hampshire thinking
about uh how a carbon Market uh is
functioning currently uh in the world
and how it's likely to affect New
Hampshire in the United States in the
coming years so that is the the very
basic focus of the bill the intent of
the bill uh I believe that it's
consistent with Our obligation to serve
our constituents both financially
economically uh and environmentally and
uh professor wheen and some of our other
uh guests here today will be able to
give you uh some really good detail
around how a carbon pricing system works
and answer questions that you might
have thank you I have a a
question this doesn't the point of X
dollar per ton doesn't make any sense to
me when you're talking about buying a
car what how would you apply it well you
would take a look at over the course of
how long a state the state plans to have
that car right how much carbon you are
using to fuel that automobile the carbon
price would affect uh the the price of
that car if it's factored into a carbon
price is factored into the expense of
operating that vehicle over its lifetime
so you'd you'd have multiple assumptions
on how long you're going to keep the car
and what kind of mileage it's going to
get and how many miles you drive it and
then put a price on on the amount of gas
consumed in the because of those yes
that's correct I assume that when the
state purchases vehicles for state
employees for example to use these are
all things that would be taken into
account how long do we have the average
vehicle in our Fleet how many miles is
it driven each year highway miles uh
those kinds of things are factored into
the valuation of automobiles right so uh
I don't see how that would be different
um when it comes to a accessing carbon
have you verified that with the the
purchasing
departments no they would have to write
up the rules for how specifically they
would account for that this bill is not
an attempt to force upon them a
particular accounting regime for that
but uh they would need to be able to in
order to implement this they're going to
would have to to write new rules and the
rules would allow
for accounting for those things um I'm
glad you s of that but it's that's not
included in the bill you have to give
them specific rule writing Authority in
order to have them do that they don't do
it
automatically if I may ask a question I
appreciate that I did not know uh if if
we are instructing them to include a new
variable in their purchasing uh I had
assumed that and obviously I'm wrong in
this case I'd assume that that would by
that would necessitate a rule to uh
allow them to incorporate a new
accounting method but uh I I appreciate
the clarification I did not know that
all right thank you um any anyone else
have a
question okay thank you very much for
your testimony thank you Charles
weeland thank you for having me you have
my written testimony so I'm Charlie
wheen I've come down from dmouth I teach
at the tuck School of business I was
trained at the University of Chicago
which will be relevant down the road
because the key issue here is that and
one of the most important ideas in
economics is that markets don't
necessarily get things right when
there's some cost that the parties don't
have to incur so classic example
historically would be smoking neither
the companies that produced the
cigarettes nor the people who bought
them bore the full cost or all kinds of
health care costs that were then borne
by the State lead paint would be another
example so the most important thing
about this bill is that it would give
the state the power to look at the real
social cost of whatever they're
purchasing and I thought your question
was spoton but if you take a relatively
simple example if you're comparing two
snow plows and one of them is ostensibly
cheaper but does a lot more damage to
the roads than it would make sense for
DOT to look at a different snowplow
that when they fully Incorporated the
cost of repairs might be cheaper in the
lifetime of the plow this goes one step
further and says if you're making a
procurement decision and one option
involves a significant amount of carbon
emissions that then do damage elsewhere
in the state whether it's climate change
related damage to the ski industry or
erosion on the Sea Coast or health
effects that are borne by the state that
in your purchasing decision you can
incorporate those
costs um you've got my written testimony
but just a couple of points I really
want to make and then we can open it up
for questions um the first is just this
key idea that markets are a terrific and
powerful thing but you do have to get
the price right and when it comes to any
kind of pollution water pollution air
pollution carbon pollution congestion
pollution if the people doing whatever
they're doing don't feel that price
you're not going to get the outcome
that's best for everybody this is a
longstanding
belief in economics and I mentioned the
University of Chicago my dissertation
adviser was Gary Becker his dissertation
adviser was Milton fredman and both
fredman well I Freedman died I think
before it became relevant but Gary
Becker who is very much of the Chicago
school was one of the earliest and most
vocal proponents for putting some kind
of price on carbon because he felt that
markets didn't get it right second
putting the cost of carbon in state
procurement decisions is a fiscally
responsible thing to do I mean we are
responsible for the full cost of
whatever we do so if buying a diesel
truck seems cheap but has emissions
consequences that are more expensive in
the long run than an electric version
then we ought to do the fiscally
responsible thing which is to take into
account that pollution and opt for the
second thing you mentioned the price and
I have to say I'm agnostic on what the
right price per ton of carbon is it's a
very complicated thing to calculate and
you have to decide whether you want to
think about just the carbon emissions as
they affect New Hampshire or whether
it's New England or whether it's Global
carbon but one thing I can say
unequivocally which is why I was eager
to come down here is the correct price
for a ton of carbon emissions is not
zero there are significant costs that
have to be incorporated and that's
something you can give rule making
authority to someone who has more
expertise around that uh and then last I
see this bill as a step in the right
direction as the representative alluded
to to in in his opening remarks ideally
we would like to get to a place where
all of our Behavior takes into account
all of the costs that we impose on
whatever parties might be that uh and
this is both to make markets work better
so that you take the Full Count of your
behavior into account and don't do
things that impose costs on other people
but not yourself but also I would say
and consistent with this my comments
about the University of Chicago it is a
more efficient way to manage carbon
pollution or any kind of pollution than
trying to regulate it away so to use an
example if I put a price on power that
comes from a polluting source and then
just step back then every facet of our
Behavior will now take into account the
true social cost of that power so you
know I may insulate my attic because my
electricity is more expensive I might
choose to buy a different car I might
drive less I might buy products with
less packaging that all follows s
through Market mechanisms because I've
correctly priced or more correctly
priced carbon the alternative if you
believe in managing pollution is I'm
going to regulate the insul insulation
in your attic I'm going to regulate your
vehicle I'm going to tell you not to
drive less those are all more intrusive
less efficient ways of getting to the
same place which is pricing the
pollution properly so back to this bill
an important First Step would be in when
you're making decisions with taxpayers
money make them in a way that is
fiscally responsible for the entire
State taking into account the burdens
placed on everybody for the duration of
whatever it is that you're procuring so
I will stop there's a it's a fairly
simple concept and but one that's quite
complicated at the same time so I'd be
happy to answer any questions thank you
questions if I can formulate
representative Simon if I can formulate
it quickly enough um just trying to wrap
my head around uh kind of this like you
said Simplicity but complexity of the
the statements that you just made so we
are fixing a very real dollar amount to
very tangible assets at the state level
while trying to take into
consideration they have to be correlated
in some way correct to real Damage Done
correct somewhere else right but without
a real mechanism to weigh that cost like
you you mentioned erosion of the
shoreline how do you how do you cost
that in a way because on the one hand
the state is incurring a burden right
it's incurring a financial burden on the
other hand somebody else let's say the
shoreline is is incurring the the
cost um how how can we make the one for
one knowing that the expense over here
is what is causing the cost over here
not some other thing that's causing the
cost over here and then who is
we're we're using Financial on this side
right but we're using environmental on
this side so who is the
agreed party in that um you know because
I would assume that in a and I'm getting
to a question uh I I assume in a
scenario like this you would typically
take the the money from the fee over
here and you would apply it to the agre
party over here to cover the cost that
they've incurred um this seems like far
too simple of a bill to take all of
those things into consideration so how
would how do you kind of square those
multi I'll take the last part first
which is it it clearly the bill does not
fully encapsulate everything that's
going on that's why I think I
characterize as a step in the right
direction the methodology which you
absolutely correctly described as being
complex is very similar to any cost
benefit analysis that you do with
regulation so you you know you say I'm
going to make an airplane
safer hand you know 127 people fewer
will die we think that's estimate we
then have to put a dollar figure on
their lives which is awkward and
uncomfortable and unrealistic but we do
it every Federal agency has a cost per
life saved and so on in this case we
would do basically the same thing we
would say okay here are the the damages
we think are happening from both climate
change and conventional pollutants
because remember if you put a tax on
carbon you're also going to reduce other
pollutants and so that means asthma and
those kinds of things uh but also
climate change and you're going to say
you're going to go to the Sea Coast
which is a good example and you're going
to say here are the damages that we
think are the result of climate change
and we're going to put a price on that
and then what economists do and again
it's more art than science but there is
science there is they will say we
believe that for every ton of carbon
that is emitted here are the damages and
the the market costs of those damages
including things like lost lives so to
repair a property or to protect a
property or to air conditioned things or
loss of Revenue to the ski industry and
then you do connect to die you say that
you know a ton of carbon We Believe
leads to these social costs for people
throughout New Hampshire or New England
and then you that's where you get your
price per ton of carbon emissions and
you start you know some usually what you
get is a range $60 to $90 or something
like that you can choose the high range
the low range but again the point is
it's not nothing and so by taking carbon
emissions into account procurement
you're at least moving in a direction
where you're making a decision that is
more consistent with the true cost to
everybody in the state follow up follow
up I so I understand the the theory
behind it but by not being accurate in
your assessment of what the carbon cost
is couldn't you very easily throw some
other cost out of whack um and then be
making poor decisions unintentionally
because your carbon pricing is way out
of out of line so for example example if
we overdo the carbon pricing on let's
say a um a plow truck in the winter time
and say okay well now the carbon
emissions of this plow truck have
skyrocketed the overall cost of the
truck so it seems like buying this other
truck over here is the better option so
then we invest in these other trucks
over here um but they're they're not as
they don't endure as well they don't
have the same kind of uh lifespan that
we thought they were going to and so
then that then in turn increases uh
maybe Public Safety maybe uh you end up
with a situation where they don't plow
as well they're not you know they don't
get the roads as clean or whatever
because they're not they weren't you
know the the evaluation changed
um it just seems like it could turn into
a a spiral where you're constantly
trying to mitigate factors that are
constantly moving because they're
they're not one for ones right I mean
it's almost impossible to come up for a
one for one cost benefit analysis in
that scenario from my perspective but am
I wrong can you help me out there no
you're you're absolutely right I would
urge you to think of it in in two steps
one is do we think that there's some
social cost of carbon emissions which is
you know conceptually an important link
an economist would say universally yes
and then the second is all right now
we're going to put a price on it which I
think you're correct it it is tricky but
as I alluded to earlier it's very
similar to doing any kind of Regulation
where airlines are pretty good
example we do things up to the point
where we think they're no longer cost
effective so we could have five pilots
in every plane because that certainly
mitigates the risk that four die in one
but that would make air travel cost
prohibitive on the other hand we do
invest in other kinds of safety and
training where we think okay given the
likely savings and we're just estimating
we think these things are relatively
coste effective so I'd urge you to think
of it in the same framework as both
private and public companies used to
weigh cost and benefits well one last
follow up follow thank you so taking the
airline industry as an example though um
the airline industry to a certain extent
ends up getting subsidized in that
scenario does it not my my concern is
that when you when you put those kind of
economic pressures into play cost spiral
to such an extent that everything
becomes
unaffordable um that that I mean just a
concern at least off the top of my head
that I have for example airline travel
does spiral out of control where it
becomes impossible for people to fly
because when you take all of you I mean
you can make expenses that make
everything you know basically untenable
um so that I guess that would be my
concern is are we not going to just
apply those same principles to
everything and find ourselves in a
situation where economics break down
because nothing's affordable anymore I
guess I would interpret it differently
which is airline travel in this country
is remarkably safe we just finished the
sixth or seventh year without a single
commercial Fatality and prices in real
terms have dropped steadily for 20 years
ever since we deregulated it and so we
you know nothing is Affordable for
everybody but we've definitely gotten to
a place where we've struck a balance
where it is remarkably safe certainly
relative to driving and more accessible
than it was okay thank you very much
appreciate it all right does anyone else
wish to uh ask a question
or represent Brown thank you madam chair
uh welcome thank you for being
here would I translate correctly into
saying from what you said and probably
not but because we can't get people to
do maybe what some would like them to do
from a carbon standpoint we're going to
force them to do it this way something
as you said that to the effect of uh uh
get it gives the the state the power to
look at the real social cost and if
polluters don't get it then we we can
derive their behavior by doing this and
I hopefully that wasn't too unclear yeah
yeah no I would not use the word Force
the whole point is we're changing the
price just like we do with taxes on
cigarettes so that the price of smoking
more closely approximates the cost of
the rest of us or any other time where
we use a tax or a price to Signal a
different incentive co-pays with
insurance or anything like that so the
alternative again if you are compelled
to do something about climate emissions
the alternative is to force people
whether it's through regulations around
automobiles or again you know
regulations around insulating your attic
or regulations on the electricity
efficiency of certain appliances so to
to the mind of an economist changing
prices allows you or the state to still
make whatever decision you want you can
buy whatever truck you want but the
price signals to whoever's doing the
behavior that you know this is the price
that's consistent with taking into
account how it affects everybody else in
our
state any other questions representative
Fitzpatrick um as a Layman I'm pretty
much
uh subject to the popular media and I
very rarely ever hear it discussed the
cost of manufactur in the let's use
electric cars for the ex example the
amount of carbon that is burned in
mining the lithium for instance and
let's not even talk about uh charging an
electric car with electricity that comes
from carbon from carbon fuels so in this
topic are there charts or variables or
some mechanism to take into account
the indirect uh uh carbon
uh pollution that comes with the uh Manu
the manufacturing of these vehicles yeah
no you rais a really good point which is
most coverage of electric vehicles in
particular is very sloppy in that regard
and so this bill if enacted properly
would and should take into account the
Environ Al cost of the lithium batteries
you know if you're driving electric car
using coal powerered electricity you're
probably worse than using something
that's dve from natural gas so if this
is done properly and I hope it would be
done properly then the full lifetime
cost from manufacturer use of the
battery where the power comes from is
the appropriate way to price whatever is
being used I mean I was up in Hover and
I parked at the dry cleaner behind a guy
it was a Tesla and the license plate
said what
CO2 and what I wanted to say is the CO2
that comes from whatever power source
you charge your car with I mean it's the
closest I've ever come to keying
somebody's car I did not uh but your
point is is important but consistent
with what we're talking about here
followup followup then is it being done
today in other words this type of a calc
calculation are are you know would it be
available now for a purchasing agent for
instance it yes it should be that if you
get the right people to do the analysis
again it's not precise but it would be
directionally correct and they would
take into account the full life cycle of
what you're doing again all of this is
much easier if you have a
broad-based price on carbon because then
you know there's a tax on whatever
energy is used to make the battery
there's a tax on whatever is used to
produce the energy for the electric car
so it's a little trickier without that
you know accurate price on carbon
everywhere but yes any sophisticated
analysis any Economist who is legitimate
uh would take into account the full life
cycle of a product or service when
they're trying to assess what the true
environmental cost is thank you thank
you madam chair represent gold thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question you said if you get the right
person to do the analysis the cost
analysis and my question would be in
this case if this bill passes for New
Hampshire uh procurement officials who
are the right people they would get to
do the cost analysis Yeah by right
person I don't mean you know Bob or S I
mean somebody who has the proper
training and is not partisan and can you
know is trained in cost benefit analysis
and has a transparent process that's
subject to input that you know it's it's
kind of like saying if you get the right
person to do cancer treatment you know
they'll get the chemotherapy you know
again it's not a specific person but
there's a process for doing this just
like there's a process for doing
something else and I would I don't know
New Hampshire state government
government well enough to know where the
expertise is on that but that is
something that if you have a state
Economist or people along those lines
this is something that they would either
be trained to do or could find the
people who could do it fairly
transparently appropriately thank you
thank
you thank you very much for your
testimony I don't see any more question
questions all right thank you for your
time okay I address represent assign
question because I have a specific
answer regarding where yes
please oh sorry I I just wanted to to
provide some clarity in this bill the
question of kind of that one toone
correlation between a cost and an effect
this uh model of where we begin with the
price and as it escalates over time
brings us in line with existing carbon
pricing
markets that's why those that's where
those specific costs come from so that
our decisions would be in line with
currently existing carbon pricing models
for example in Canada and the European
Union and and those um and and I believe
speaker will be coming up soon can can
talk about this that modeling is based
on it's the
intergovernmental panel on climate
control looking at trying to keep global
warming below at at at 1.5 degrees
centigrate looking at $135 a ton as the
likely price point that would achieve
that goal and that is and we could
disagree however one feels about the
ipcc the fact of the matter is that the
Canadian market and the European market
trading major trading partners for the
United States are using these price
points and American
are going to be paying penalties as we
export into those markets based upon
those models so this model was
specifically and these numbers were
specifically uh chosen because they will
bring us in line
with trading
partners Simon thank you um just because
I'm looking for some light reading to do
on the side would you be able to get me
any of the information on the models
they use to come up with their
calculations yes absolutely and in fact
uh uh John Gage who will be testifying I
believe he has sent the committee uh his
testimony and it contains a number of
hyperlinks uh that contain all of this
information I'm happy to follow up with
that as well but uh all of the modeling
that was used in this case is contained
within the documentation that Mr Gage
sent with his testimony okay great thank
you you representative Dolan thank you
madam chair the um question I have is is
with with our current consumers uh
struggling mightily to keep up with
additional costs of living and so forth
who who do we expect is going to be
paying these carbon taxes that we're
talking about here this additional
carbon I I thank you very much for for
your uh for your question I also wanted
to clarify we are not talking about
changing the market and we are not
talking about a tax that is applied to
consumers we are talking about State
spending decisions so some of these
larger questions like the one that you
ask which I think is a very real and
important question I would argue is not
a relevant question to this particular
case what we're actually arguing is that
taxpayers will save money if the state
uses a more fiscally responsible which
is we're arguing that that's what this
is it will actually save taxpayers money
so the larger question um and I and I
thank the the professor for his expert
testimony but the larger question of
markets is not the question for this
bill this bill is specific to how the
state makes procurement decisions it's
not a tax and it's not meant to drive
consumer Behavior we are talking about
the consumer that is us which is the
state of New Hampshire and how we make
decisions about
procurement B leus yeah just to clarify
if I understand the bill
correctly um all it does is require a
report on the uh aggregate um the amount
of you know Carbon that's going to be
emitted based on all the the state or
just State activities times whatever
your numbers are in here is that correct
no and I should grab a copy of the bill
I apologize for not having immediately
in front of me but there are kind of two
parts to the bill one is that the state
will take a proxin proxy carbon pricing
into account when it makes purchasing
decisions the second part short I think
sentence in the second part of the bill
if I remember correctly is that the
state will also
publish uh in its annual Energy report
and will publish uh these you know the
outcome of their assessments you know so
if they're going to say we need to
purchase X number of vehicles for our
Fleet or as our annual energy reports do
now right thinking about the projects
that the state has in line for
renovation or construction right when
those um uh calculations are made about
how much those the energy footprint of
of those buildings it'll go into our
annual Energy
report
you okay I'm still looking at it but
okay thank you any other questions thank
you thank you for allowing me to come
back to answer that question John
Gage
thank you chairwoman I'm John Gage from
Windham I'm a volunteer of a national
nonpartisan Grassroots organization
called citizens climate Lobby we have
1,000 800 members in New Hampshire and
I'm pretty sure every one of them
supports this bill um can I have a count
of the online support and opposition of
the bill if that's possible uh we do you
have that
um that question do you have the on
count of online
support from the
portal we don't have it handy thank you
will'll will be included okay there was
170 to3 the last time I
checked um so this is not a case where
we need to come up with a carbon price
there's actually kind of two ways you
can price carbon one is what is the
social cost of it which is an extremely
complicated thing which depends on
factors like the discount rate which um
make it render it pretty much impossible
to figure or we can pick a temperature
Target that we want to hold warming to
uh economists can estimate the carbon
price necessary to reduce emissions to
reach that Target with complimentary
policies and that is where this price
came from on page two of the handout um
there's a quote from the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change is global it's the special report
on global warming of 1.5 degrees came
out a couple years ago um
looking at all of the analysis of um
published economics
on what prices are needed to reduce
emissions to achieve a 1.5 degrees
Target the line says estimates for below
1.5 degrees pathway range from $135 blah
blah blah blah blah in
2030 so $135 in 2030 is the minimum
price um it goes much higher than that
because uh it might take a much higher
price to drive emissions down this is a
global price on fossil fuels fossil fuel
use
um the ipcc Report was generated by
hundreds of climate scientists
volunteering their time reviewing tens
of thousands of climate science reports
and some of the world's leading
economists um looking at adaptation and
mitigation options so we don't know the
exact price to hold warm to an exact
temperature but this is our best
estimate is somewhere between $135 and
$6,000 in 2030 and Rising 8 to $10 per
ton through the rest of the century so
we just picked the minimum of that price
range for 1.5 degrees world we picked
that because that's the temperature that
every country in the nation in the world
has committed to achieving um driving
emissions down about 50% by 2030 and
down a Net Zero by 20 2050 we need a
really high carbon price and that's
about half of the solution and there's a
whole bunch of compl complimentary
policies that are also
needed but this is a bill to save the
state money by paying attention to
what's going on we're not trying to save
the world here we're trying to save
taxpayer
dollars we can do that by
anticipating This Global carbon price
that's going to come to New Hampshire so
sometime it's not a stable price this
price is rising over time it's not that
we can start 10 years later and start at
that price 10 years after 2030 uh it's
going to be $100 more per ton it'll be
200 $230 per ton will be the minimum
price that the world needs on fossil
fuels the US is standing still there's a
growing carbon price gap between where
the US is and where the GL Global carbon
price needs to be but also where our
trading partners
are um as representative germon
said Europe is at $85 per ton of CO2
today um it has tripled in the last
three or four years uh and it will
continue going up because um they want a
higher price Canada is using a policy
called carbon Fe and dividend they are
taxing the fossil fuel industry for
Carbon on fossil fuel production and and
rebating all the money back to its
citizens um now this is smart most
families come out ahead more money than
they have right now after paying the
trickle down higher costs um my
organization is trying to get Congress
to do this carbon fee and dividend a
bill has been in Congress the last four
sessions it was introduced in 2017 as a
bipartisan byal bill um last session it
achieved 96 co-sponsors in the house
in the discussions of the reconciliation
package it was included a variation was
included and it missed being included by
one
vote so what can we do in New
Hampshire we can anticipate a carbon
price in the price of fossil fuels not
now but in the future so when we buy
something to heat a building for the
State uh we can use current prices or we
can an
anticipate the minimum carbon price uh
that the experts say is required to meet
the global
goals that seems reasonable to me
there's lots of fiscally responsible
reasons to do this uh we will save money
by Saving avoiding stranded costs we uh
conquered steam um was the first bill I
ever tesi first time I ever testified in
front of a State Hearing um
I was asking if anybody had considered
the cost of the pollution if we started
using natural gas to heat state
buildings instead of um oh the the
conquered buildings instead of some
other me mechanism um the bill ended up
deciding that they were going to heat
the buildings with natural gas so they
bought $25 million worth of gas uh
equipment and heating systems to heat
these buildings um now when a carbon
price price comes and the price of
natural gas starts to rise rapidly um
that decision may turn out to be a poor
one as far as the cost of heating these
buildings um this equipment will
probably become obsolete because of the
cost of using it compared to other
options and we're going to end up buying
heat pumps earlier uh to replace them
because that will be cheaper than
continuing to use gas we can avoid
making similar mistakes with our vehicle
Tren vehicle purchases and our building
heating purchases with this bill we're
taking a conservative price it's the
minimum of the experts price range to
drive emissions down as needed to meet
the globally committed to targets and
we're not taxing anybody we're not
spending extra money on something to do
good we're taking a look at the chance
of a federal carbon price coming down on
New Hampshire and we are using using our
insight to save money by purchasing
things that will be cheaper to operate
uh in the long
run so a couple carbon pricing signals
um there's some graphs in this document
you can see there's 73 countries and
regions that are pricing carbon now
that's on the bottom of page two um page
three has some of the prices Canada is
using carbon Fe and dividend and they
will be at $135 per ton in 2030 they're
Rising $15 a year and they're rebating
all the money back to Canadian citizens
um and then the bottom of page three is
the EU that's a cap and trade system
which I don't recommend because you can
see what it does to the price business
is like a predictable price so a
steadily Rising fee um is what we are
advocating Congress to and fully rebed
back to households to protect households
so I'm trying to give you my insight as
a almost eight-year um volunteer with
citizens climate Lobby um we have some
of the best economists um working with
us and we listen to The Experts and we
get informed about what's going on in
the world I wanted to share some of what
I've been learning um from that
organization with you so that you can
help reduce my taxes in the future and
the benefit of this is that sometimes
it's a trade-off between the economy and
the
environment this bill is a trade-off
between helping the economy saving
taxpayer dollars and helping the
environment and doing the opposite
wasting taxpayer dollars buying
equipment that's going to become
obsolete before it's time uh and
allowing our state to uh produce more of
it more than its fair share of pollution
going
forward thank you for your testimony are
there any questions from the committee
representative
Schmidt
thank you madam chair and thank you for
being here John so which committee did
you testify before uh previously oh I
can't remember the name of it actually I
did show up in the conquered monitor
they got my name wrong oh they got my
town wrong they said John Gage from
Lincoln from Windham uh I can look that
up for you though repres representative
well well it was this in the last couple
of years because I've been on this
committee for 18 years uh and it wasn't
this committee you were for it was I
would guess it probably Commerce uh
where or maybe Finance uh but probably
Commerce because it seems like it's a
Commerce kind of Bill it certainly is
not our kind of Bill no yeah U more
likely it's legislative Administration
yeah no sorry I wasn't trying to blame
this committee I was just using it as an
example of uh a case where the the the
state bought $25 million of equipment
that is going to be obsolete uh and
replaced before it's turned out to have
saved the state money all right thank
you follow up followup so uh but the
thing is that this is not the kind of
Bill we ordinarily deal with and so
we're trying to Grapple with the uh the
very concept that the bill you know puts
before us but also the presentations
that we heard from the sponsor and from
Professor wheen uh and it's a
dramatically different approach in in
each case you're a practical politician
in a way or practical Economist and
you're talking about something that
legislators are used to considering at
least um in the aggregate when we were
hearing about on the house floor if not
in committee um so your
question the the question is uh and
you've given us a some documentation
here which uh we we will certainly look
at closely but the question is um how do
we get our handle on it because we're
going to be making a decision on this
particular bill and I don't know whether
we're going to go to a subcommittee
because uh I haven't heard from the
chair on that regard if it's if it will
go it's assigned to representative gr's
subcommittee if they choose to take it
up that's where we'll deal with it okay
would you be available to come before
the subcommittee uh to talk about this
because I think you have to wrestle with
the with the details your approach is
easy more easily grasped than I think
than the previous testimony that we
heard which was coming at it from a very
different angle as you undoubtedly
realized when you heard it yes I would
be happy to uh come work with the
subcommittee I um you
know what we heard from the expert is
correct uh and he also said to do that
efficiently we need to charge the fossil
fuel industry a carbon tax um so that
the cost of doing everything re is
reflecting the price of pollution and
those things um but that's not a state
level thing uh we're working at that at
the federal level um so how do we do
this pragmatically at the State uh we
don't have to get the price right but we
should
be uh anticipating some price and if we
anticipate too much of a price according
to the
ipcc the world is not going to meet its
targets so they might start low but then
they're going to have to raise those
prices uh to drive emissions down as
they as they want uh if we do it too low
we've saved some money but we haven't
saved as much as we might have um if we
do it too high we'll R we reduce more
pollution that will cost us a little
more than our cheapest um option but I
think people in New Hampshire wouldn't
mind making a mistake and reducing in a
little more pollution than optimal uh
and I'm confident this is a low price
because the IP uh sorry the EPA just
came out with a new social cost of
carbon dioxide emissions at $190 per ton
um that's up from about
$5 five or six years ago um the longer
the world takes to put a price on carbon
everywhere the higher the Target price
is because we haven't been reducing
emissions in the meantime uh it's a a
scale where the longer you wait the more
it's going to have to cost
you thank you refen Simon thank you
madam chair so this was uh the
information that I believe I asked
representative ger for where this comes
where where your numbers come from um
and if I understood you correctly you're
saying that essentially what this
calculation took into effect was where
we wanted to see temperature uh
percentage increase over time then we
took the amount of fossil fuels that we
were burning or whatever and we figured
out what the tax needed to be to keep
our global warming at a certain rate is
that correct did I hear you correctly on
that the ipcc special report on one and
a half degrees of warming came out with
these numbers based on what you said
yeah they've calculated and this is only
half of the solution to reduce emissions
there's in addition to pricing
pollution because we're starting 30
years too late we we now have to do
complimentary policies to pick up the
rest of the slack um the price range is
so big because there's other variables
also the the natural price of fossil
fuels varies because of market
conditions um the rate of economic
growth varies um there's a lot of
unknowns so picking the minimum we know
that's going to be too low because
that's kind of a terrible economy a very
high fossil fuel prices which probably
wouldn't go together um and so you know
we are being being conservative with
these numbers um including with the us
epa's estimate of the social cost of
carbon at $190 per ton um we'll get
there eventually but but by the time
we're at $190 a ton rising at a $10 per
year rate um the US government will have
adjusted that upwards again I'm sure
thank you represent Dolan and then
represent
Brown thank you madam chair
um I'm going to say that what I'm
hearing is a lot of so attempts at
Social
Engineering and uh and what happens when
you do that you're what you're actually
trying to do is you're driving
electrification let's Electrify
everything I have a my question is in
your various charts and Analysis have
you have you started to consider the
stress on our electric grid that's
struggling mightily to keep up with all
this electrification we know that's my
main question but our objective evidence
is that California's a ahead of us
excuse me ahead of us with this and
they're having rolling blackouts brown
outs mandates don't charge your electric
vehicles because we can't the electric
grid can't handle it what have you what
have you done to analyze the stress on
electric grid to be able to handle
initiatives like this yeah there's a lot
of work going on right now with
permitting reform um in Congress um
because the inflation reduction act
subsidies have opened up the floodgates
to uh produ to generate clean energy now
the problem is there's not power lines
to go from where we can generate clean
energy to where we need it um Congress
has to change some pering rules New
Hampshire may have some pering rules
that need to be o open up to make those
things possible we have New Hampshire is
in a good situation that we have a lot
of lines coming from seabook and there's
a lot of wind off the coast that we can
bring power into to where the sebr lines
start from um but I you know I'm not an
expert I would say from a New Hampshire
perspective uh Independence is important
and I would like to see the state focus
on helping people become energy
independent themselves uh a a household
battery and solar panels um can make you
you know independent when you have a an
ice storm um you know so we could help
people um produce energy locally in
micro grids um on over parking lots over
buildings uh I I don't think this is
social engineering as professor willan
said we have a market failure when
there's free pollution um the right cost
incentives are not aligned and so we're
we're not manipulating people into doing
what we want them to do we are
reflecting the true costs of using the
different energy options in the price of
of those options so we get an efficient
market we get you know car carbon fee
and dividend is the tax the fossil fuel
industry for its pollution of a polluter
fee and rebate the money back to
households this addresses a market
failure in the most costeffective way we
we just correct the prices so that
buyers and sellers and investors can
make more fully informed decisions based
on price you don't have to know climate
science to figure out whether the Tomato
from Chile is better to buy than the
Tomato from down the street the one from
Chile will be more expensive because it
had to fly here um getting the prices
right frees everybody from trying to
figure out what the right thing to do is
you look for the cheapest thing and
that's the right thing to do um you
don't have to tell Banks not to you know
loan money to fossil fuel industry they
see huge risk those those those giant
projects will not pay off because clean
energy projects will be more profitable
um when there's when we truly reflect
the costs of the different
options if you one followup our
constituents I'm
sorry our constituents
um aren't that concerned about the price
of whatever carbon uh thing this is
going to work out to be when their when
their power is out their electric power
is out and we have a lot of outages in
New Hampshire because of the weather and
excuse me representative Dolan this bill
is not about the electric grid and it's
uh you're going way off Target on this
let me bring it back um be happy to talk
talk with you afterwards about it I'm
I'm very interested in the problem
you're right it's not not relevant to
this one um this particular bill but it
we we we do need to do work in parallel
with all of these things I there's no
one thing that's going to solve
everything we just want I want to save
the state money that's what this bill is
really about is thank you I know some
things about what's going on with carbon
pricing around the world I want to share
it with the state so that the state can
make um strategic decisions to save
taxpayer dollars thank you
representative Schmidt in my opinion I
think we're wasting our time at the
moment what we need to do is get to to
the subcommittee where we can get to the
the det
because we're we're all over the place
here great lack of understanding we need
to get to subcommittee hearings are very
inefficient in terms of dealing with
their
problem thank you representative
Brown uh would you like me to go ahead
or would you prefer to go that way no
he's he's set his piece okay
um couple questions about some things
that you said why uh why is equipment
going to become obsolete you buy a
diesel truck it's going to become
obsolete before it's worn out could you
explain that yeah it's going to become
more expensive to operate than buying a
electric vehicle that will be much
cheaper to operate over a period of
excuse me sorry I'm sorry his his
assumption is that the at some point the
federal government will impose a carbon
tax and therefore the cost of fossil
fuels will
increase so follow up followup the
vehicle won't be obsolete but
it's paying to operate it will be cost
prohibitive is that better that's a
better way to term it yes and and that's
basically what this Bill is saying we
want to you know account for the the
cost of operating these things over time
um building in a price on carbon um
because it's like it's increasingly
likely um and so by anticipating that it
may be we'll be buying diesel trucks
because there's no other options
um so but uh a sedan that somebody is
driving 100 miles round trip a day um we
can save money I I just bought an
electric vehicle four weeks ago and I
did a cost accounting
myself what is the what is the cheapest
way to do the traveling that I want to
do I wasn't looking at my carbon
footprint I was looking at the cost of
ownership of this car I hold on to cars
for 10 years what is it going to cost me
and there's a break even point
uh after several years an electric
vehicle and then you're saving money
because electricity is so much cheaper
per mile than gasoline now if we if
federal government prices carbon while I
own this vehicle I'll have even saved
more
money thank you follow one A different
question if I
might uh you also mentioned free
pollution and could you could you expand
on that a little bit and the reason I
asked is we have the Clean Water Act we
have the Clean Air Act we have uh
requirements on Wastewater we have
requirements on power plants that they
have to do X Y and Z to manage their
pollution so I I want to know what you
mean by you think there's free pollution
yeah sure um human civilization has
increased carbon dioxide by 50% in the
air since the Industrial Revolution half
of that in the last 30 years if you look
at the 10,000 year um chart of carbon
dioxide it it was 280 parts per million
until 150 years ago and now it's 50%
more of that and it shot up rapidly this
is pollution we're changing the chemical
and physical nature of our world and
that's costing us in many ways um
stronger storms more flooding droughts
heat waves fires these are worse now
they're more expensive um the cost the
IMF estimates the sub subsidies that we
give the fossil fuel industry both
direct and indirect uh to be7 trillion
dollar a year globally and hundreds of
billions of dollars in the US most of
them are not explicit subsidies for oil
depletion allowances and things like
that they're implicit subsidies of the
damages from the pollution that we as a
society have to pay after the fact and
these include um personal risk uh health
problems um insurance going up uh were
you know the national flood insurance um
were were socially um paying more and
more from the impacts of the pollution
the carbon dioxide pollution from fossil
fuels this is free it's a subsidy to the
fossil fuel industry right now we are
giving the fossil fuel industry a
subsidy and we were paying the
consequences later so situation is that
the carbon dioxide has not been declared
a pollutant in the sense that it is
affected by the Clean Air Act or the
Clean Water Act therefore there's
no regulatory control yeah and until
citizens united uh this was not a
partisan issue um George HW Bush
campaigned on the White House Effect
will take care of the greenhouse effect
um the fossil fuel industry has confused
um the media and manipulated us into not
being sure what to do they've just been
delaying uh sensible legislation to call
a spade a spade CO2 emissions from
breathing are not pollution we that's
part of the short-term carbon cycle CO2
from carbon that we dig out of the
ground that was put there millions of
years ago when there was a lot more CO2
in the air but now it's underground
we're putting it back up in the air
we're changing the physical nature of
our atmosphere and that's changing the
physical nature of the surface of the
Earth and the oceans and this is costing
us dearly you know not just in dollars
but biodiversity loss ecological system
uh degradation you know in our own New
Hampshire way of living with the ski
industry and and snowmobiling we're
losing our Winters uh on both ends and
it's Winters coming later and it's
ending earlier and it's more variable in
the middle uh these are costs of
pollution um because uh we knew from
science decades ago this would happen it
is starting to happen now we can see it
uh that's why at the federal level we
need to price carbon and use border
carbon adjustments to push our carbon
price around the world and whole free
polluting countries accountable this
will help put a price on pollution
around the world that's what I work on
in my day volunteer job um what I'm
trying to do for you is what I've
learned is it's quite likely carbon
pricing is coming
um I want to save our state some money I
want to save some tax dollars I want you
guys to make good decisions that that
are fiscally responsible and they have
the side benefit of reducing pollution
which I think all of us would like to
reduce taxes and have a clean New
Hampshire thank you for your concern are
there any
questions thank you very
much Barbara sou thank
you
good afternoon I'm Barbara Souther I'm
from Bradford New Hampshire and I just
want
to ask this committee if you would
please not be shortsighted on this I
know it seems to be human nature to be
shortsighted we do that all the time but
we really need to think about the future
because we're in a
fantastically huge transm transition
right now not just in New Hampshire but
the whole United States and the whole
all the countries the whole globe we're
really moving fast and so we need to
take a lot of things in con into
consideration that we didn't used to
take into consideration like when your
purchases something you know you want to
you want to take into consideration not
what it costs today but what is it going
to cost in three years five years 10
years because if you don't you're going
to pay for it you're going to have to
retrofit all kinds of things and and uh
get new new vehicles new new heat pumps
like John was saying and
uh you know it's just very important to
think about all of these
factors that's really all I need to say
please please think about the
future thank you for Testimony
representative gold hi hi it's nice to
see you here I'm glad you made it down
from Bradford and I've enjoyed our
conversations on this topic and I just
want to thank you well thank you for
serving other
questions don't see y thank you've been
very
eloquent Walter
Payne Hi H I'll just try to uh bring up
a few things that others have mentioned
um so first um Professor whan mentioned
uh that um well just the starting
principle is that no one wakes up up in
the morning and says they want to burn
as much coal or consume emit as much CO2
as possible no one does that they wake
up thinking they want to get someplace
they want to keep their house warm in
the winter and cool in the summer they
maybe want to have some fun maybe they
want to fly somewhere and they want to
buy things that are made using energy so
um the key point is that we buy things
on price and the reason people use
fossil fuels and have for about 200
years now is that they're very
convenient they're energy dense and
they're very cheap um so but they but
they they're only cheap as Professor
Willam pointed out because we're not
paying the costs of them so I filled up
my car works out great for me works out
for Exxon Mobile not so great for my
kids even worse if I were to have
grandkids um even worse where I to live
in
Bangladesh um which I would not argue as
a political point in this country uh but
it'll be worse for everyone including
people in New Hampshire as John pointed
out we're losing our winners um we're
getting just incredible numbers of ticks
in the summer and spring and fall so so
the the the key the key thing to do is
to make fossil fuels include those costs
that are going to be borne by people in
the future who are not here to vote on
it um and there are two ways you can do
that you can either put the fee on on
carbon which of course is the most
efficient way to do it or you can
subsidize the
non-carbon uh uh sources of energy so
I'll give give you just an example
because a lot of this is very abstract
so let's take uh cars um we've had for
more than 10 years now a federal tax
credit on EVS which pays uh which gives
back in in in taxes owed 7500 bucks to
people who buy a full electric vehicle
and uh so let's look at what that means
in terms of the price the implied price
of carbon so if you buy a u a 21 Mile a
gallon car and you drive at 11,000 miles
a year that emits about five tons of
carbon a year okay um that the average
American emits about 16 tons a year so
five of that is if they have a car um
and let's say you keep that car for 15
years which isn't you know the average
life of a car in America is like 12 13
years on the road so uh 5times 15 that's
75 tons of carbon that are going to be
emitted over the life of this
conventional gas car getting 21 miles a
gallon and conveniently the the federal
EV credit was
$7,500 and still is actually it's got
some little uh adjustments but
so so that means that the federal
government is saying that it's worth
$100 a ton to
avoid the emissions from a gas car by
buying an EV card 75 5 time 15 is 7 75
700 divid by 75 is
$100 now that $100 a ton is in the
ballpark of what experts consider the
the uh social cost of carbon as people
pointed out it could be
195 could be 135 it's certainly way
greater than zero as Professor whin
argued and the only thing I'd say about
that I'm not here to try to tell you
what it is but there's a big debate
right now um as to whether the adverse
effects of climate change are in fact
coming much sooner for a given level of
carbon di carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere then people had modeled and
if that's true
and it's a hot debate that among
scientists then the actual effects of of
of hot very high levels of carbon
dioxide are going to be worse and sooner
than we had expected so far which would
mean of course the social cost of carbon
maybe even even at $195 may be grossly
underestimated but let let's just stick
with that so hundreds in the general
bpark but let's look at let's look at
the assumptions on that and see if
that's actually what the Federal
government is currently paying to reduce
a ton of carbon the buyer of a a Tesla
for instance is probably not buying if
he didn't buy a Tesla probably would not
buy a 21 Mile g a gallon car there are a
lot of nice hybrids made by you know
Honda or Toyota that get almost 50 a
gallon so let's say they get twice as
much miles per gallon that means they
emit more like 2 and a half tons of
carbon per year that would mean
therefore that the implied cost of
carbon is more than double 100 let's say
it's 200 okay which is
conservative if you're following me here
because we're only avoiding half of the
carbon by buying the Tesla instead of
the car so it's really $200 a ton of
carbon that the federal government is is
currently paying then let's also
consider as people have pointed out uh
that the person charging the r is not
likely to be using 100% % renewable
energy some people have the panels on
their roof and they use the charge a car
but a lot of people are going to be
using some mixture of natural gas
uh uh hydroelectric in certain parts of
the country coal even not so much in New
Hampshire um that's certainly going to
mean that you're not saving the full two
and a half tons of carbon a year by
driving EV and then furthermore as uh I
think representative O'Brien or F bat
could point out producing an EV Tak
makes more carbon than producing a
conventional car particularly the
batteries are very carbon intensive to
produce so um and then finally and a big
thing is some of the people that buy EVs
do not buy them because of the tax
credit they buy them because they go Z
to 60 in 3 seconds or they really like
them for other reasons and for those
people the $7,500 credit to take an
extreme example Leonardo DiCaprio
probably would have bought a test
regardless that $7500 is straight out
the window in terms of reductions in
carbon because you're giving money to
someone who's going to already do that
so a lot of people um have looked at
this and they've said that the actual
implied cost of carbon that the federal
government's EV tax credit is based on
comes out to more like $3 $400 a
ton Which is higher than most estimates
of of the social cost of carbon now on
the one
hand even if you care about climate
change uh that seems
excessive but on the other hand
especially if you care about climate
change it seems kind of crazy to be
spending three or $400 of federal money
taxpayer money to prevent one ton of
carbon be admitted by a car that is
instead where some instead buys an EV
and yet charging zero cost of carbon for
you or I or anyone else in this country
walks into the the L nearest Chevy
dealer and buy a 17 Mile a gallon
Suburban that will be on the road for
the next 15 years so this is I think a
pretty concrete example of the
inefficiency of subsidies relative to
carbon fees because first of all the
carbon fee is going to take into into
account everything involved in the
transportation system producing the
car driving the car not just you know
the and and the size of the car so what
we have now is we have an EV Market
where the manufacturers like it's it's
tough to make money making these things
so we have a profusion of 6,000 pound
EVS that are uh at
best maybe neutral with a small gas car
in terms of Co carbon total carbon
emissions right so that's not good
policy it's not good policy from the
taxpayer standpoint it's not good policy
from the uh yes from from climate change
excuse me that you're you're talking
primarily about federal government
decisions I am but it's all related well
I hope you would you would draw it to be
specific to this bill and right well I I
was trying to address some of the
situation questions for instance that
representative Simon asked about the
right and as regards to representative
Dolan's point that this bill sounds like
social
engineering um I I I would dispute that
because as people have pointed out what
we're really doing right now is running
a massive geoengineering project we are
we are injecting massive quantities of
CO2 into the country into the atmosphere
quantities that are so large that the
scientists who first figured out that
CO2 would create a greenhouse effect
which was before the Civil
War could not fathom the quantities that
would be necessary to actually change
the atmosphere to an appreciable degree
and we've gotten there 150 years later
and we're we're shooting past these
targets uh at this you know in an
unbelievable um rate um so so we have a
market failure and to stop our
geoengineering EXP experiment we have to
apply the Classic Market tool of pricing
carbon and the sooner New Hampshire does
that with their own uh the argument for
doing in New Hampshire there there are a
couple of reasons one um the explicit
costs uh that are there right now should
be
acknowledged to there is we are going to
eventually have carbon pricing at the
federal level simply because nothing
else is going to be
efficient and three it will serve an
example to the rest of the country that
reasonable people and a reasonable State
can come up with something that is going
to help everyone and the politics I may
make a mention of the politics of
climate change are not very promising
right now given that the single most
important policy is pricing carbon and
even the most moderate candidate on the
Republican side uh has said the market
will solve this problem which does not
happen if you have a market failure
that's the definition of market failure
the market will not solve the problem
and her solution is one of her proposals
is actually to eliminate the federal gas
tax which of course is the exact
opposite direction we need to go in the
federal gas tax already doesn't even
cost cover the cost of Highways so so
it's not a promising situation
politically on one hand right right but
will say that um one thing that is
promising is if when you ask
people um how much they care about
climate change is it a big threat what
we want to do about it you get some
interesting things so if you look at
Republicans even though only a quarter
of them see it as a big threat and a
half of them actually uh only a half say
that it's basically a man-made
problem two thirds or more say they
favor federal tax credits for carbon
capture and
sequestration now if you don't think
that climate change is man-made by
burning fossil fuels or that it's a big
problem favoring a federal tax credit
for carbon quest uh capture and
sequestration is like favoring a tax
credit for digging holes and filling
them back in I mean why would you
possibly bother so I think that there's
a lot of you know Kabuki going on here
people have uh in our extreme partisan
politics really negative partisanship
where anything one side favors the other
side automatically opposes and this
happens on both sides by the way we've
seen it in Immigration yes on the
Democratic side that
that people instinctively have to say
they believe something isn't happening
even if their own eyes tell them that
that it is and you see this when older
people are more likely to buy deny
climate change even though obviously
people who can remember the 70s or the
60s are obviously more confident that
the climate has changed than someone who
was born 20 years ago right because it's
changed a lot more so um let me I I know
I'm trying I'm a little disorganized
because everyone else said most of the
useful stuff um let me just see here uh
uh the only other thing well I I'd
mentioned regarding uh representative
Dolan's Point how is anyone going to
afford anything how are we're going to
address the least fortunate Among Us um
the the the most sensible proposal for
pricing carbon is uh carbon fee and
dividend where instead of the carbon fee
being a tax that is just held by the
federal government to spend wherever
they want 100% of the revenues from this
fee which would be sign significant
because the fee would go up every year
until the problem is
solved um are are rebated back to
American households on a per capita
basis adult gets a full share kids get a
half share and if you think every adult
would get back the same amount
regardless of how much they're paying in
through the carbon fee and if you think
about it uh the yeah the the least
affluent people say a guy living in a
small apartment in Manchester and taking
city buses his cost of living will go up
almost not at all because he's using
very little fossil fuels okay anyone
who's has large
Mansions uh speedboats or to take an
extreme example a private jet is going
to be paying a lot into this of these
fees but he only going to be getting
back the same rebate that the guy living
in the in the one B apartment in
Manchester gets so the people at the
bottom of the of our economic hierarchy
are are going to be coming out ahead
people who are extremely affluent who
let's be honest are actually the biggest
sources of the problem are going to be
paying in a lot more than they get back
so um that's that uh very difficult to
talk about an issue that that has
obviously a lot of implications but um
you know as Barb said I think it's
important to government has to accept
reality and kind of has to look ahead to
the Future and the future our future in
many respects is determined we're going
to have climate change and its effects
for at least decades to come the goal is
to try to minimize those and it's the
role of government to to accept those
facts and and the future that's coming
rather than just wish it away so but I
appreciate your time thank you thank you
for your
testimony representative Schmidt
yep sounds like you've thought about
this for more than a few hours um so are
you willing to come to the sub commit
committee and help us with some
Progressive I use the word cautiously um
some Progressive steps here in New
Hampshire on this bill uh sure sure I'm
sure there who are you and where are you
from uh I live in exor I'm just a
private citizen but yeah I have thought
about climate change I mean
basically um sounds like you've got an
educated background in The Sciences uh
no no I studied e college but that's
congratulations on having an excellent
teacher okay representative Gard thank
you madam chair just I want to address a
couple things you said just because I
think it's important but I think we're
looking at this we see it from a
different point of view and I just want
to kind of clarify this establish it so
losing to Winners and so forth totally
agree but are you aware that the US
government this is from an MIT
technology review article of 2019 the US
government has approved funds for
geoengineering research you mentioned
geoengineering from the car aspect but
the US government for the first time
authorized this is 2019 funding for GE
engineering controversial idea that we
could counteract climate change by
reflecting heat away from the planet so
they're injecting all these chemicals
above us to create these artificial
clouds to reflect sunlight I just want
to bring that up that we're trying to
address this issue I I'm just he
mentioned it so I think it's game I
gentlemen I'm sure it would be a
fascinating discussion but I don't think
you
need there there's some research on that
the United States is not currently
trying to uh modify the climate by
injecting things in the atmosphere yeah
all right thank you very much I'm going
to close the hearing on House Bill
whatever it
is
1486 may I just make a comment not a
question just a short little comment
oh just for everybody's enjoyment the
sap is running in Bradford as we speak
the who sap to make syrup which usually
happens in March and April all right
well that's good to know you
[Music]
will no you burn wood to it's too
water oh
joy